I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi, Jenna. We are here. We are surrounded by lamps. So both of us have some progressive eye sight issues. Yes, deteriorating eyesight. And we both just got new glasses. But here's the thing. We need lots of light. I need a well-lit room. I am that person at a restaurant now who is holding the little
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你们制作终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好，安吉拉。你好，珍娜。我们到了。我们被台灯包围了。我们俩都有一些进行性视力问题。是的，视力在恶化。我们俩刚配了新眼镜。但问题是，我们需要充足的光线。我需要一个光线充足的房间。我现在就是那种在餐馆里拿着小
votive candle over the menu. Yeah, that's right. And using your iPhone light. I try not to use the iPhone light because it's just so incredibly embarrassing. But it's sometimes comes to that. Oh, I've let it go. I'm iPhone light. I would like to point this out. And maybe I shouldn't put it in our stories. We have an addition to the overhead light that comes in this room, right? There's track lighting. There's all these bulbs. We have brought in lamps. I'm talking floor lamps, guys, like that you see at Target, you know, the floor lamps. We have one, two, three, four, four around us right now. Four floor lamps. We're ladies who love lamps. We're
蜡烛对着菜单照的人。没错。还要用你的iPhone手电筒。我尽量不用iPhone手电筒，因为那太尴尬了。但有时不得不这么做。哦，我已经不在乎了。我就是iPhone手电筒用户。我想指出这一点。也许我不该把它写进我们的故事里。除了这个房间里的顶灯，我们还加了灯，对吧？有轨道灯。有这么多灯泡。我们还搬来了台灯。我说的是落地灯，伙计们，就像你在塔吉特百货看到的那种，你知道，落地灯。我们现在周围有一、二、三、四，四盏灯。四盏落地灯。我们是爱灯女士。我们是
the lamp ladies. We're the lamp ladies. And we're here today to talk to you about Scott's Tots. Season six, episode 12, written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky and directed by B.J. Novak. Our very own B.J. Novak. Yeah. Here's a summary. It's time for Michael to face the music on an empty promise that he made 10 years ago. Ugh. Here's the promise. He told 15 elementary school students that when they graduated from high school, he would pay their college tuition. Mm-hmm. Because he believed he would be a millionaire by that time. But he's not. And he can't do it. Nope. So he's gonna have to go to their school and
灯光女士。我们是灯光女士。今天我们在这里和你们聊聊《斯科特的学童》。第六季第12集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，B.J.诺瓦克执导。我们自己的B.J.诺瓦克。是的。这是剧情摘要。迈克尔是时候面对他10年前许下的空头支票了。呃。承诺是这样的。他告诉15名小学生，等他们高中毕业时，他会支付他们的大学学费。嗯哼。因为他当时相信自己会成为百万富翁。但他没有。他做不到。不。所以他必须去他们的学校，
tell them today. In person. Meanwhile, Dwight hatches a diabolical plan to try and get Jim fired. He literally calls it a diabolical plan. Yep. He printed out a little outline of his plan. So as many of you know, this episode is considered the cringiest. Yeah, Gene and I were talking. As we prepped for this episode, we both went online. There are so many articles that list the cringiest moments or cringiest episodes of the office. And Scott's taught pretty much makes number one on almost all the lists. Well, we're very excited today because we are interviewing the director of this episode, B.J. Novak. We're gonna ask him all
今天告诉他们。当面告诉他们。与此同时，德怀特制定了一个邪恶的计划，试图让吉姆被解雇。他真的称之为邪恶计划。是的。他打印了一份计划大纲。正如你们许多人所知，这一集被认为是最尴尬的。是的，吉恩和我聊过。当我们为这一集做准备时，我们都上网查了。有很多文章列出了《办公室》中最尴尬的时刻或最尴尬的剧集。《斯科特的学童》几乎在所有榜单上都排在第一位。好吧，我们今天非常兴奋，因为我们要采访这一集的导演B.J.诺瓦克。我们要问他所有
about it. B.J. Hello. Welcome to Office Ladies. Thank you. Welcome back. I've been on. Wait, are we starting with some B.J. sass? I think we just started with sass already. I love it. Whoa, whoa, whoa. That's not my, that's not my brand. It's only right. It's the Ryan brand. It's the Ryan sass coming through. Yes. Welcome back to Office Ladies. Thank you. Is this your third? Second. Second. You've no memory of any of this. Do I know you? Have we met? Who are you? How'd you get out of Zoom? No, you're on my IMDB right now. It's like, oh, wow. I guess I worked
关于它的事。B.J.你好。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。谢谢。欢迎回来。我来过。等等，我们要以B.J.的毒舌开始吗？我想我们已经开始毒舌了。我喜欢。哇，哇，哇。那不是我的，那不是我的风格。这是对的。这是瑞安的风格。瑞安的毒舌出来了。是的。欢迎回到《办公室女士》。谢谢。这是你第三次来了吗？第二次。第二次。你对这些一点记忆都没有。我认识你吗？我们见过吗？你是谁？你是怎么从Zoom里出来的？不，你现在就在我的IMDB上。就像，哦，哇。我想我确实和
with him. Okay. B.J., thanks so much for being here. Yeah, I keep staring at you too. It's pretty cool. I'm like, are they the same people? I know I did this before, but. Well, we're the same, just, you know, slightly rounder. Yeah. No, I was talking to Brian Baumgartner for the first time in forever, not in person. And I was like, when I see him, is he even Brian to me anymore? Is it just like Kevin? Like, it's this weird blur when it's been so long. Well, I totally get that though because Jen and I also live in this weird kind of surreal place where we see you every week, every week, but we. Oh, because you rewatch. Yeah. And we rewatch
他合作过。好的。B.J.，非常感谢你能来。是的，我也一直在盯着你看。这太酷了。我在想，他们是同一个人吗？我知道我以前做过这个，但是。好吧，我们还是我们，只是，你知道，稍微圆润了一点。是的。不，我很久以来第一次和布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳聊天，不是面对面。我在想，当我见到他时，他对我来说还是布莱恩吗？还是就像凯文？当时间过去这么久，这是一种奇怪的模糊感。好吧，我完全理解，因为珍娜和我也生活在这种奇怪的超现实空间里，我们每周都见到你，每周，但是我们。哦，因为你们在重温。是的。我们重温
multiple times as we do research and stuff. So we'll watch each episode three times at least, you know? Wow. Yeah. And it's. You're in that phase. Your character's in that phase right now where like every week you're doing something weird, like wearing a fedora or glasses or like a weird patterned vest. Yes, that's what you do when you don't know what to do with the character. But you guys are living in our brains in this like, this predated place, you know? Obviously, you are the DNA of you enjoy watching the stuff you've done. Yeah. And I'll say this, my lore of the show before we started this rewatch was that it was
很多次，当我们做研究之类的。所以我们至少会看每一集三次，你知道吗？哇。是的。而且。你正处于那个阶段。你的角色现在正处于那个阶段，每周你都在做一些奇怪的事情，比如戴软呢帽或眼镜，或者穿一件奇怪图案的背心。是的，当你不知道该怎么处理这个角色时，你就会这么做。但你们活在我们的脑海里，在这个预设的地方，你知道吗？显然，你们是你们喜欢观看自己所做事情的DNA。是的。我会说，在我们开始重温之前，我对这部剧的了解是，它
only good for a few seasons and then it was like, meh. I know. We were really snobby about it. And it's not true. I thought season three, I was like, this show's over. But it is not true at all. We're in the middle of season six. We're like cruising right into season seven. And it is a pleasure and a joy to watch. There were episodes where I thought, oh, that I remember when we were doing them that we were like, oh, so broad and and Jen and I are watching them and laughing our asses off. Yeah, like mafia. I was like this when we shot mafia, I was like, what has happened to us? Why is it as a mechanic? It is just it's amazing. Like
只有几季好看，然后就，一般般。我知道。我们当时真的很势利。这不是真的。我以为第三季，我就想，这部剧完了。但这根本不是真的。我们正处于第六季的中段。我们正顺风顺水地进入第七季。观看它是一种快乐和享受。有些剧集我以为，哦，我记得我们在制作它们时，我们觉得，哦，太粗俗了，珍娜和我在看它们时笑得前仰后合。是的，比如《黑手党》。我在拍《黑手党》时想，我们怎么了？为什么它是机械师？这简直太神奇了。就像
there's just nothing wrong with it. I mean, some of the bigger swings are more clear why you doubt them like Kevin and the chili. Did we talk about Mindy and I were like, no, this is the dumbest. It's like, okay, the cold open Kevin makes chili. He loves it. He walks up, he spills the chili. And we're like, that's the joke. We're like this intellectual show and it's like a classic. Yeah. But it's also like, you know, when you're in a school play, when you're a kid and your parents see Saturday night or Friday night and it was so much better Saturday and the parents like, I know you think that to me, it's just you in a play. Okay. Yeah. And
它没有任何问题。我的意思是，一些更大的尝试更清楚为什么你会怀疑它们，比如凯文和辣椒。我们聊过吗？明迪和我当时想，不，这是最蠢的。就像，好吧，冷开场凯文做了辣椒。他很喜欢。他走过来，把辣椒洒了。我们想，这就是笑话。我们以为这是部知识分子剧，结果它成了经典。是的。但这就像，你知道，当你小时候在学校演戏，你的父母在周六或周五晚上看，周六演得好多了，父母说，我知道你这么想，对我来说，那只是你在演戏。好吧。是的。而且
I feel like to fans, it's like, okay, but it's Jim and Pam and it's still the office guys. I'm sorry that season six wasn't season. It's very funny. I get it. It's the same show. Oh, that's really good. Actually, that's so true. Thank you for coming on today. Oh, I love it. So that we could talk about God's Tots, which you directed. It was your directorial debut of the office. Of anything. Yeah. Now, had you not directed a webisodes before this? Oh, that's true. I did the webisodes. Yeah. But you know, the first substantial thing. Do you guys remember anything about the show? The two of you. Angel, you want to just handle this on your own? I mean, I
我觉得对粉丝来说，就像，好吧，但这是吉姆和帕姆，伙计们，这仍然是《办公室》。很抱歉第六季不是那一季。它非常有趣。我明白了。这是同一部剧。哦，那真的很好。实际上，那太真实了。谢谢你今天来。哦，我喜欢。这样我们就可以聊聊《斯科特的学童》，你执导的那一集。这是你执导《办公室》的处女作。也是任何作品的处女作。是的。现在，你之前没执导过网络剧吗？哦，那是真的。我做过网络剧。是的。但你知道，第一部实质性的作品。你们记得关于这部剧的任何事情吗？你们两个。安吉拉，你想自己处理吗？我的意思是，我
think you got this. I got this. Well, we have some stats to throw at you about some reviews of Scott's Tots. We do. Just so we get clear, did you bring me on to answer for Scott's Tots? No. Apologize. Okay. Okay. No, no, no, no. I know some of this, but please let's. No, not at all. Not at all. Okay. What are they, what are, what are they saying? Scott's Tots is widely referred to as the cringiest episode of the office. The majority of our fan questions that we got for this episode were not questions at all. They were actually just comments on how cringy and uncomfortable it is for people to watch this show, how a lot of people skip it when they do a rewatch of the show. We found an
想你搞得定。我搞得定。好吧，我们有一些关于《斯科特的学童》评论的统计数据要抛给你。我们有。为了清楚起见，你带我来是为了回答关于《斯科特的学童》的问题吗？不。道歉。好吧。好吧。不，不，不，不。我知道一些，但请让我们。不，一点也不。一点也不。好吧。他们说什么，他们说什么？《斯科特的学童》被广泛称为《办公室》中最尴尬的一集。我们为这一集收到的绝大多数粉丝问题根本不是问题。它们实际上只是关于人们观看这部剧时感到多么尴尬和不舒服的评论，很多人在重温这部剧时会跳过它。我们发现了一篇
article on bustle.com that was titled this, the scientific reason office fans really can't watch Scott's Tots no matter how hard they try. Oh, there's a whole article. There's a doctor and everything. Yes. Dr. Judith Orloff is the author of the empath survival guide. And she said, quote, fans might very well avoid this episode to avoid something painful that's hard to face in themselves. There is a subreddit with almost 17,000 subscribers that is titled cannot watch Scott's Tots. And it is still regularly updated. This was my favorite. What? One person on this subreddit said that Scott's Tots is like the moment Toby put his hand on Pam's knee but stretched out for a whole episode. DJ, at the time,
Bustle.com上的文章，标题是这样的，《科学原因：办公室粉丝无论如何努力都无法观看〈斯科特的学童〉》。哦，还有整篇文章。有一位医生和所有东西。是的。朱迪思·奥洛夫博士是《共情者生存指南》的作者。她说，引用：“粉丝们很可能会避开这一集，以避免面对内心深处难以面对的痛苦。”有一个拥有近17,000名订阅者的子版块，标题是“无法观看〈斯科特的学童〉”。而且它还在定期更新。这是我最喜欢的。什么？这个子版块上有一个人说，《斯科特的学童》就像托比把手放在帕姆膝盖上的那一刻，但拉长了一整集。B.J.，当时，
did you know? Did you know that you were directing what would become the cringiest episode of the office? I had no idea. It seemed great. You know, I was a sign the script, loved it. And it was only much later. I think it's a sign of how deep into the show I was or we all were that we did not have a foot in the real world, not that it was an unrealistic episode, just that that's exactly what Michael would do. That's exactly what Michael would feel. I also think that, you know, we can talk about it creatively. It makes a lot of sense to me. I don't know if people are responding to it. It seems like no one's responding to it's a it's a bad episode or it's Michael wouldn't do that. It's more just like that's
你知道吗？你知道你正在执导后来成为《办公室》中最尴尬的一集吗？我完全不知道。看起来很棒。你知道，我被分配了剧本，很喜欢它。直到很久以后。我认为这标志着我或我们所有人对这部剧的投入程度有多深，以至于我们没有脚踏实地，并不是说这是一集不现实的剧，只是迈克尔确实会那样做。迈克尔确实会有那种感觉。我也认为，你知道，我们可以从创造性的角度来谈论它。这对我来说很有意义。我不知道人们是否对此有反应。看起来没有人回应说这是一集糟糕的剧，或者迈克尔不会那样做。更多的是，就像那
so hard to watch. So it is consistent, I think with the show. So to us, it was it was it just made sense. It was consistent. I don't remember anyone saying you can't you can't do this. But to me, I mean, it is heartbreaking from both the kid's perspective, sure, but from Michael's perspective, which is the one you just happened to be following in the office, which is that he to me, the key to the episode was that Michael was so sure that he would be successful, that he could make this promise. Yeah, he's so believed in himself. Yes, it's not to me, it's not about the lie. It's not about what ended up being a lie or a broken promise. It's it's Michael's he got carried away with his generosity, his belief in himself.
太难看了。所以我认为这与这部剧是一致的。所以对我们来说，它只是有意义。它是一致的。我不记得有人说你不能，你不能这样做。但对我来说，我的意思是，从孩子的角度来看，这令人心碎，当然，但从迈克尔的角度来看，也就是你在《办公室》中碰巧跟随的那个人，对我来说，这一集的关键是迈克尔如此确信他会成功，以至于他可以做出这个承诺。是的，他如此相信自己。是的，对我来说，这不是关于谎言。这不是关于最终变成谎言或违背承诺的事情，这是迈克尔，他被自己的慷慨、对自己信念冲昏了头脑。
So to me, it was a very, I mean, maybe this is what people can do. It's a very, very lovable version of Michael Scott, as well as a heartbreaking version of Michael Scott. And it's sort of the whole series in in an incredibly distilled, uncomfortable way from the Michael Scott point of view, when you look at it like that. To me, it's maybe one of the most Michael things Michael has ever done 100%. I love the line so much. I felt like it was like everything you need to know about Michael when he says, I've made some empty promises in my life, get hands down, that was the most generous. Yeah, it's like so perfect. DJ, I made a list because there are a bunch of articles that list the cringiest episodes of the office.
所以对我来说，这是一个非常，我的意思是，也许这就是人们能做的。这是一个非常，非常可爱的迈克尔·斯科特版本，也是一个令人心碎的迈克尔·斯科特版本。从迈克尔·斯科特的角度来看，当你这样看时，这在某种程度上是整个系列以一种极其浓缩、不舒服的方式呈现。对我来说，这可能是迈克尔做过的最迈克尔的事情之一。100%。我非常喜欢这句台词。我觉得这就像你需要知道关于迈克尔的一切，当他说，“我一生中做过一些空头承诺，毫无疑问，那是最大方的一次。”是的，这太完美了。B.J.，我列了一个清单，因为有很多文章列出了《办公室》中最尴尬的剧集。
Get ready. You wrote most of them. They're Prince Family Paper, Diversity Day, Sexual Harassment, and Chair Model, all of which you wrote. Yes. Yes. Chair Model. You remember Chair Model, where Michael falls in love with a woman in a magazine and finds out she's died and he goes to her grave. He lost his wife in 50 years. Paul Lieberstein wrote a lot. I love that episode. Paul is the source of the darkness on that one. And look, I wrote a lot of very joyous stuff too. I wrote a lot of the Jim and Pam. I wrote Threat Level Midnight, which is a very joyful episode. It's not like I'm the Prince of Darkness on the show. And also look, they were what? How many 100 episodes? I worked on more than
准备好了。你写了大部分。它们是《王子家族纸业》、《多元化日》、《性骚扰》和《椅子模特》，所有这些都是你写的。是的。是的。《椅子模特》。你记得《椅子模特》吗？迈克尔爱上了一个杂志上的女人，发现她死了，他去了她的坟墓。他失去了他的妻子50年。保罗·利伯斯坦写了很多。我喜欢那一集。保罗是那一集黑暗的源头。而且看，我也写了很多非常快乐的东西。我写了很多吉姆和帕姆的故事。我写了《午夜威胁》，那是一集非常快乐的剧。我并不是这部剧里的黑暗王子。而且看，它们是什么？有多少100集？我参与了超过
half of them. I'm not just this dark figure. I'm proud of it. I'm less dark now though because again, I do hear this and I do go, oh my God, how is I capable of some of this? Especially when I see Ryan Howard, I'm like, oh my God. I don't see any villain like this. Here's the Mashable article that comes out after this episode. BJ Novak, Prince of Darkness of the Office. No, BJ. We love my God. No, I think the dark is important. And I think that I remember after season one, which was six episodes, and I think all of them ended pretty darkly. The pilot hot girl, I mean, we had that nice moment at the end of diversity, but the pilot diversity day, hot girl, healthcare, extremely dark. Basketball, I don't remember.
一半。我不只是这个黑暗人物。我为此感到自豪。不过我现在没那么黑暗了，因为再次，我确实听到了这个，我确实会想，哦，天哪，我怎么能做出其中一些事情？特别是当我看到瑞安·霍华德时，我想，哦，天哪。我没看到任何像这样的反派。这是这一集之后出现的Mashable文章。B.J.诺瓦克，《办公室》的黑暗王子。不，B.J.。我们爱我的上帝。不，我认为黑暗很重要。而且我认为我记得第一季之后，那是六集，我想它们都以相当黑暗的方式结束。试播集《辣妹》，我的意思是，我们在《多元化日》结尾有那个美好的时刻，但试播集、《多元化日》、《辣妹》、《医疗保健》，极其黑暗。《篮球》，我不记得了。
Office Olympics and basketball maybe were a little more positive endings. But we had sort of a big group meeting that Greg led about, okay, what are we going to do differently in season two? And there was a lot different. And one of them was three out of four endings should be positive. And then one is just for us, meaning Paul. He was like, we're not going to totally sell out, but the British had ended dark every time more or less. And we had been ending dark every time more or less. And so the new thing was, you know, so I guess Scott's Tots was definitely one of those four one for us. Yeah. But again, I do, I do think it's an interesting, it is a deep interesting one. It's not that it's not part of the canon.
《办公室奥运会》和《篮球》可能结局稍微积极一点。但我们有一个由格雷格领导的大型小组会议，关于，好吧，我们在第二季要做什么不同的事情？有很多不同之处。其中之一是四分之三的结局应该是积极的。然后一个是留给我们自己的，意思是保罗。他说，我们不会完全出卖自己，但英国版几乎每次都以黑暗结局。我们也几乎每次都以黑暗结局。所以新事物是，你知道，所以我猜《斯科特的学童》绝对是那四个中的一个，留给我们自己的。是的。但再次，我确实，我确实认为这是一个有趣的，这是一个深刻有趣的剧集。并不是说它不是正典的一部分。
It is very difficult. I agree. I agree. I think though it is Michael, it's honestly Michael trying to do something good, believing in himself, knowing, well, I don't think he knows he's going to fall. Well, look how much he believes in Pam and her, her art. I know he is. He is such a believer. He is, you know, um, and so his belief got ahead of him. And this is by far, you know, exactly like the line you quoted, this is the biggest consequence of all of all is his belief. You know, yeah. Now I we should remind people or I should remind people I, I wish I had I admire I did not write the episode. This was a Lee Eisenberg and Gene Szybnicki episode. And I hope it doesn't sound like I'm disowning it either
这非常困难。我同意。我同意。但我认为这是迈克尔，老实说，这是迈克尔试图做一些好事，相信自己，知道，好吧，我不认为他知道他会失败。好吧，看看他有多相信帕姆和她的，她的艺术。我知道他是。他是一个坚定的信徒。他是，你知道，嗯，所以他的信念超过了他自己。这是迄今为止，你知道，就像你引用的那句台词，这是他信念带来的最大后果。你知道，是的。现在我应该提醒人们，或者我应该提醒人们，我，我希望我有，我钦佩，我没有写这一集。这是一集李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基的剧集。我希望这听起来不像我在否认它，
because I know we talked about so many people are uncomfortable. You know, these are two of I think the most brilliant, you know, writers backbone of the show when a lot of the original staff was burnt out. These guys took the ball and a lot of the sort of center central seasons of the, of the office that people that were is really humming. That was Lee and Gene were just turning out scripts and revising scripts. They're not even credited for. So those guys were really an incredible backstop for that. But you know, the look, Gene in particular, I think is the best one liner writer in office history. He's the one who wrote, I'm not superstitious, but I'm a little stitious, you know, so I guess he wrote that line. But yeah, I mean,
因为我知道我们谈论过，很多人感到不舒服。你知道，我认为这是两位最杰出的编剧，是这部剧的支柱，当许多原始员工精疲力竭时。这些人接过了接力棒，在《办公室》的许多核心季中，人们觉得它真的在运转。那是李和吉恩在不断地写剧本和修改剧本。他们甚至没有被署名。所以这些人真的是一个令人难以置信的后盾。但你知道，看，吉恩特别，我认为是《办公室》历史上最好的单行词作家。是他写了，“我不迷信，但我有点迷信”，你知道，所以我猜他写了那句台词。但是的，我的意思是，
maybe we're getting a little off track, but that is sort of this incredible distillation of why we love Michael so much and why he's made everyone's life so impossibly difficult, which is sort of the heart and the comedy of the series. But it's not usually that intense, you know. Right. Well, what was it like, BJ? You talked about, you know, Lee and Gene as the writers, but you went from writing to directing on the office. And what was that shift like to go from the writer's room to being the director of the episode? It felt very intuitive. I took it very seriously, but I overprepared. I don't think I did any
也许我们有点偏离主题了，但这在某种程度上是为什么我们如此爱迈克尔，以及为什么他让每个人的生活都变得如此不可思议地困难的不可思议的提炼，这在某种程度上是该系列的核心和喜剧。但它通常没有那么强烈，你知道。对。好吧，B.J.，那是什么感觉？你谈到了，你知道，李和吉恩作为编剧，但你从《办公室》的编剧转到了导演。从编剧室到成为该集的导演，那种转变是什么感觉？感觉非常直观。我非常认真地对待它，但我准备过度了。我不认为我在第一集上做得
better on the first one than I did on the fifth one that I did. But I think that it's just very interesting what is required to leap from writer to director. And I think to an extent actor to director is so much the confidence to picture yourself saying action and cut. Did you get any advice from anyone before you started directing? Yes. I got the best advice and I pass it on to anyone who directs. So the first piece of advice I got, first of all, it's good advice in general. Ask everyone for advice. People love giving advice. So anytime you wish you had advice and you're shy, ask them. People will talk your ear off. So I asked everybody, what's your advice for directing? And I should
比我在第五集上做得更好。但我认为从编剧到导演的飞跃所需要的东西非常有趣。我认为在某种程度上，演员到导演更多的是那种想象自己说“开始”和“停”的自信。你在开始执导之前从任何人那里得到过建议吗？是的。我得到了最好的建议，我把它传给任何执导的人。所以，首先，我得到的第一个建议，首先，它通常是一个好的建议。向每个人寻求建议。人们喜欢给建议。所以任何时候你希望得到建议而你又害羞时，问他们。人们会喋喋不休地跟你说。所以我问每个人，你对执导有什么建议？我应该
also, we should clarify, directing an ongoing TV show is incredibly different. The actors know the characters. The writers know the story. The director's photography and cameraman know how to shoot it. If you just stand there and nicely and intuitively and confidently ask everyone, how would you shoot this? How would you schedule this? Did that feel good to you? You're fine. Because the show is set in the pilot stage, whereas a movie or a limited series, which is essentially like a long movie, you have to establish, is there music in the show? Is this a very colorful show? Is this a little bit of a campy wink-wink show? Is it super deadpan? You have to establish all these things. But on an ongoing show, it's
还要，我们应该澄清，执导一部正在进行的电视剧是非常不同的。演员了解角色。编剧了解故事。摄影指导和摄像师知道如何拍摄它。如果你只是站在那里，友好、直观且自信地问每个人，你会怎么拍这个？你会怎么安排这个？那样感觉好吗？你就没问题了。因为这部剧是在试播阶段设定的，而电影或限定剧，本质上就像一部长电影，你必须确定，剧里有音乐吗？这是一部非常多彩的剧吗？这是一部有点露骨的眨眼剧吗？它是超级冷面吗？你必须确定所有这些事情。但在一部正在进行的剧里，它
kind of like, look, I took it super seriously because it's an amazing first step, but it's not nearly as hard coming into an ongoing show. The advice I got from Randall Einhorn, our longtime director of photography, and later our most prolific director on the show, I said, do you have advice? He said, yes. Direct the cameras like their actors. I said, what do you mean? He said, you'd never tell an actor, shout this line and cut it off after three seconds, right? You tell them why. So you never tell the camera, swing to the left on this line and punch in on that. You'd say, this is where we catch Pam in her lie. So I would creep up to her and find that moment
有点像，看，我非常认真地对待它，因为这是一个了不起的第一步，但进入一部正在进行的剧并不难。我从兰德尔·艾恩霍恩那里得到的建议，我们长期的摄影指导，后来是我们剧中最丰富的导演，我说，你有建议吗？他说，有。像对待演员一样对待摄像机。我说，你是什么意思？他说，你永远不会告诉演员，喊出这句台词并在三秒钟后切断它，对吧？你告诉他们原因。所以你永远不会告诉摄像机，在这句台词上向左摆动并推入那个。你会说，这是我们抓住帕姆撒谎的地方。所以我会在她身上爬行并找到那一刻
and don't let her out. You know what I mean? And it inspires so much more creativity. It's so much more respectful. And you're more likely to get what you're looking for. And I've extended that to direct to everyone, like their actors. You don't tell the costume department, I want them in a suit. You say, this is a character who's so insecure that he takes himself. He tries to tell the world he's important. I want them in a suit. Every day he'll wear a suit. Now the costume designer is so excited. You know, rather than, oh, she went to Sears and got a suit and then you say, make it look fancier. No one understands what you're doing. No one's motivated. Whereas actors, that's how you talk to an actor, right? And people
不要让她逃脱。你知道我的意思吗？它激发了更多的创造力。它更尊重人。而且你更有可能得到你想要的东西。我已经把它扩展到像对待演员一样对待每个人。你不会告诉服装部门，我想要他们穿西装。你说，这是一个如此不安全的人，以至于他把自己。他试图告诉世界他很重要。我想要他们穿西装。每天他都会穿西装。现在服装设计师非常兴奋。你知道，而不是，哦，她去了西尔斯百货买了一套西装，然后你说，让它看起来更花哨。没有人理解你在做什么。没有人有动力。而演员，这就是你和演员交谈的方式，对吧？而且人们
know that much more. So direct everyone like their actors is, I think, the best advice I got on that show. Other advice I got later, the other two great pieces of advice, a friend Lee Winnell, who just wrote and directed Invisible Man, which I thought was great. And he had been a writer forever. And he said that he actually took a panel on directing at the writer's Guild of American. He's like, BJ, I won't do his Australian accent. He's like, it's the kind of thing you get junk mail for. Come to the seminar, blah, blah, blah. It was the best thing I've ever been to in my life. It was like John Wells. It was Catherine Bigelow and they were giving practical advice and cynical advice and inspiring advice. And
知道得更多。所以像对待演员一样对待每个人，我认为是我在那部剧里得到的最好的建议。我后来得到的其他建议，另外两个伟大的建议，一个朋友李·温纳尔，他刚刚编剧并执导了《隐形人》，我觉得那很棒。他一直是个编剧。他说他实际上在美国编剧工会参加了一个关于执导的小组讨论。他说，B.J.，我不会模仿他的澳大利亚口音。他说，这是那种你会收到垃圾邮件的东西。来参加研讨会，等等。这是我一生中参加过的最好的事情。就像约翰·威尔斯。那是凯瑟琳·毕格罗，他们给出了实用的建议、愤世嫉俗的建议和鼓舞人心的建议。而且
he was like, it was the best thing I've ever been to and everything I tell you is going to be from that. This advice was the best thing you can do as a director is watch the movie in your head as much as you can. Whenever you're in doubt, just take a walk and watch the whole movie in your head again and again and again. And then when you're in a production meeting and someone says, what does the room look like? You just say what you see and they figure it out. You don't need to know what the lens is and what the lighting scheme is. If someone says, you know, what are they wearing or how do you want to shoot this? You know, you can say, oh, I picture close ups, right? I picture all year like looking from a distance,
他说，这是我参加过的最好的事情，我告诉你的每一件事都将来自那里。这个建议是，作为导演你能做的最好的事情就是尽可能多地在脑海中观看电影。每当你怀疑时，就去散散步，一遍又一遍地在脑海中观看整部电影。然后当你在制作会议上，有人问，房间看起来像什么？你只要说出你看到的，他们就会弄清楚。你不需要知道镜头是什么，灯光方案是什么。如果有人说，你知道，他们穿什么，或者你想怎么拍这个？你知道，你可以说，哦，我想象特写，对吧？我想象整年就像从远处看，
you know, it will have the same effect as if you studied everything in school because the point is to know the heart. So watch the movie in your head. The other piece of advice that's so simple. This was, I have a friend whose father is Al Ruddy who produced the Godfather. And I asked him if he had any advice and directed, he said, you only need to know two things to direct what you want and how to get it. And I was like, you know what, I think that's the best advice I've gotten for anything because those are two very hard things in a way, knowing what you want is even harder. But all of us can approach, okay, if you know what you want and how to get it, you'll accomplish anything. And we do that
你知道，它会有和你在学校学习一切一样的效果，因为重点是了解核心。所以要在脑海中观看电影。另一个建议太简单了。这是，我有一个朋友，他的父亲是阿尔·鲁迪，他制作了《教父》。我问他是否有任何建议，执导，他说，你只需要知道两件事来执导，你想要什么以及如何得到它。我就想，你知道吗，我认为这是我为任何事情得到的最好的建议，因为这两件事在某种程度上非常困难，知道你想要什么甚至更难。但我们所有人都可以接近，好吧，如果你知道你想要什么以及如何得到它，你就会完成任何事情。我们这样做
for all sorts of things. And how to get it includes asking someone for help or to understand something or to explain something or to beg them for a favor, you know, or to, you know, grind them down because they're just not getting it and whatever it is or inspiring them or whatever you need to get it. So that's, you know, what you want and how to get it. And then I told them, I ran into him and I was like, you gave me the best advice ever. And I quoted him and he's like, Oh, there's a third part, I forgot to tell you, you got to know when you got it. I was like, I don't like that one. You're not wrong. You're not wrong, but it's not as good a quote. And I said to him, he's like, no, no, you don't
为了各种各样的事情。而如何得到它包括寻求某人的帮助，或者理解某事，或者解释某事，或者乞求他们帮个忙，你知道，或者，你知道，磨练他们，因为他们就是不明白，无论它是什么，或者激励他们，或者无论你需要什么来得到它。所以这就是，你知道，你想要什么以及如何得到它。然后我告诉他们，我遇到了他，我说，你给了我最好的建议。我引用了他的话，他说，哦，有第三部分，我忘了告诉你，你必须知道你什么时候得到了它。我就想，我不喜欢那个。你没错。你没错，但它不是一个好的引语。我对他说，他就像，不，不，你不知道
know what, I think he just worked on a movie with some director took forever. I was like, Al, no, this is not, this is Godfather part three. This is not as good. So I just quote the first two parts. That's so true, BJ. I know, you know, Angela and I changed our whole lives because we wanted to get something. We wanted to get a quality of life. We wanted to be able to make it to soccer practice. We want to take our kids to school. I didn't know you play soccer. I'm sweeper. Nothing's getting into the goal. Um, no, we just wanted to make our families first. And yeah, just have agency over our own schedules and our time and,
什么，我想他刚和某个导演合作了一部电影，花了很长时间。我就想，阿尔，不，这不是，这是《教父3》。这没那么好。所以我只引用前两部分。那太真实了，B.J.。我知道，你知道，安吉拉和我也改变了我们的整个生活，因为我们想要得到一些东西。我们想要得到一种生活质量。我们想要能够赶上足球训练。我们想带我们的孩子去学校。我不知道你踢足球。我是清道夫。没有什么能进入球门。嗯，不，我们只是想把我们的家庭放在第一位。而且是的，只是对我们自己的日程安排和时间有代理权，
and, uh, pour that into our family as a priority. And we didn't know how to get it. That took a long time. It took a lot of experimenting years of kind of griping to each other. Yeah. But then eventually we did it. And, and here we are interviewing you on our podcast, which is the result of our wanting to get something. And we did know how to do it. No, as you were talking, but it's so much easier to figure out how to do it. Like the worst person to work with someone who doesn't know what they want. Oh my God, what a nightmare, right? You knew what you wanted. So now you're like, I have no idea how to get this, but like you figure that out. But you're right. I've worked with directors who don't know what they want.
而且，呃，把这作为优先事项投入到我们的家庭中。我们不知道如何得到它。那花了很多时间。那需要很多实验，多年来互相抱怨。是的。但最终我们做到了。而且，我们在这里采访你，在我们的播客上，这是我们想要得到某样东西的结果。而且我们确实知道怎么做。不，当你说话时，但弄清楚怎么做要容易得多。就像最糟糕的合作对象是不知道自己想要什么的人。哦，天哪，真是噩梦，对吧？你知道你想要什么。所以现在你就像，我不知道怎么得到这个，但就像你弄清楚了。但你是对的。我和不知道自己想要什么的导演合作过。
And it really puts everybody through the ringer. You know, you're changing clothes a million times and you're doing the role different ways. And everyone, it really runs people into the ground, but someone with a very clear vision, then you're on set and you're like, okay, well, how do we do it? How do we make this happen? Like just give me something that I can hang on to, right? If your vision is clear, we'll get there. Oh, I have one other very cynical piece of directing advice and it does not make the top three, but it really worked. And someone said to me who had worked on the office said, here's my advice, pick one shot that's a special shot. Doesn't have to make sense. It just like
这真的让每个人都陷入了困境。你知道，你换了一百万次衣服，你用不同的方式扮演角色。每个人，它真的让人们筋疲力尽，但一个有非常清晰愿景的人，然后你在片场，你就像，好吧，好吧，我们怎么做？我们怎么实现这个？就像给我一些我可以坚持的东西，对吧？如果你的愿景清晰，我们就会到达那里。哦，我还有另一个非常愤世嫉俗的执导建议，它没有进入前三名，但它确实有效。有人对我说，在《办公室》工作过的人说，这是我的建议，选一个镜头，那是一个特殊的镜头。不需要有意义。它只是像
it stands out. It doesn't quite fit. And the network will tell you, you're a great director because they'll notice it and they'll feel proud. And I did that. I think it was maybe in the web, I said, no, I think it was in this, there's a shot where Creed is like standing by the doorway and waiting to go into the room. I don't know which episode it was in, but literally the network is that call me person is like, BJ, you are a great director. And it was that shot. And it was like, it was a stretch that the, I mean, it didn't break the office style, but that is a cynical thing. And definitely when you see, like I've joked the easiest way to win an Oscar is to be a cinematographer and decide to shoot the movie
它脱颖而出。它不太合适。网络会告诉你，你是一个伟大的导演，因为他们会注意到它，他们会感到自豪。我做了。我想那可能是在网络剧里，我说，不，我想是在这一集里，有一个镜头是克里德站在门口，等着进入房间。我不知道是哪一集，但字面上网络就是那个打电话给我的人，就像，B.J.，你是一个伟大的导演。就是那个镜头。而且它就像，这是一个延伸，我的意思是，它没有打破《办公室》的风格，但那是一件愤世嫉俗的事情。而且绝对当你看到，就像我开玩笑说赢得奥斯卡最简单的方法是成为一名摄影师并决定拍摄电影
in glorious black and white, like anything that calls attention to yourself as a director is so rewarded. So that is my cynical advice. If you do want to, if you're, if you have the chance to direct something and you want people to think you're good, do something visually unusual, which will follow the intelligence. Do one odd thing and every critic and every person will say, ooh, you know, you're good. Whereas if you just shoot intuitively, like Harold Ramis, you know, is a great director. He directed a lot for us, but, you know, his movies are classics, but no one talks about him as a great director because he didn't call attention to himself. Rob Reiner to me is the greatest director of our lifetimes.
以辉煌的黑白，就像任何引起人们注意你作为导演的事情都受到如此奖励。所以这是我愤世嫉俗的建议。如果你确实想，如果你有机会执导某事，并且你希望人们认为你很好，做一些视觉上不寻常的事情，这将跟随智慧。做一件奇怪的事情，每个评论家和每个人都会说，噢，你知道，你很好。而如果你只是直观地拍摄，像哈罗德·雷米斯，你知道，是一位伟大的导演。他为我们执导了很多，但是，你知道，他的电影是经典，但没有人谈论他是一位伟大的导演，因为他没有引起人们对他自己的注意。罗伯·雷纳对我来说是我们一生中最伟大的导演。
Because if you look at the movies he directed, they are the classics of their genres. He did spinal tap, which is the classic mockumentary stand by me classic coming of age, princess bride classic family movie, few good men classic. And I don't just mean classic, I mean the epitome of their genre, Harry Metzali epitome of romantic comedy. And people don't talk about him, you know, because he just did it so right that he was invisible. If he had had like, you know, like an overhead camera in the ceiling fan, Harry Metzali, everyone's saying he's such a great director. But, you know, Fiji, that reminds me of a piece of acting advice that I got that I use all the time.
因为如果你看他执导的电影，它们是各自类型的经典。他做了《摇滚万万岁》，这是经典的伪纪录片，《伴我同行》经典的成长故事，《公主新娘》经典的家庭电影，《好人寥寥》经典。我指的不仅仅是经典，我指的是它们类型的缩影，《当哈利遇到莎莉》浪漫喜剧的缩影。人们不谈论他，你知道，因为他做得太对了，以至于他隐形了。如果他在天花板风扇上有一个，你知道，像一个头顶摄像机，《当哈利遇到莎莉》，每个人都会说他是一位伟大的导演。但是，你知道，斐济，这让我想起了一个我一直使用的表演建议。
What? So in any project, if it's a TV show or a movie, the, my acting coach said, you pick one moment for your character that you decide in this project is your big moment of realization, a confession, something, you pick one. And before you say that line, you pause, move forward, and then say it, and it will blow people away, and he said, even in auditioning, if you have just an audition scene, you pick one line in that audition scene where you pause and then you lean in before you say that line and you'll get the part every time. I swear to God, after I got that piece of acting advice, I went on a bunch of auditions,
什么？所以在这个项目中，如果是一部电视剧或电影，我的表演教练说，你为你的角色选择一个时刻，你决定在这个项目中这是你的大时刻，顿悟，忏悔，某事，你选一个。在你说那句台词之前，你停顿一下，向前移动，然后说出来，它会震撼人们，他说，即使在试镜时，如果你只有一个试镜场景，你选择那场试镜场景中的一句台词，在那里你停顿一下，然后你在说那句台词之前倾身，你每次都会得到那个角色。我发誓，在我得到那个表演建议后，我参加了一堆试镜，
I got callbacks for like 12 auditions in a row when I did that little move in thing, and I still use it. I still use that. That's amazing. Okay, this is so funny to me. Is that in your book? It's not in my book because I didn't want to steal his thunder. Oh, got it. Robert Devonzo, my acting coach, and I put him in the book and I said, call this guy
我连续获得了大约12次试镜的回调，当我做那个小动作时，我仍然使用它。我仍然使用那个。那太神奇了。好吧，这对我来说太有趣了。那在你的书里吗？它不在我的书里，因为我不想抢他的风头。哦，明白了。罗伯特·德万佐，我的表演教练，我把他写进了书里，我说，给这个人打电话
and take his class. He'll give you the best advice. But I guess now I've put it on my podcast. So sorry, Robert. My acting coach did something similar. She was this very amazing old, older woman and she said that she was auditioning for a movie. She was from France and she had an old crown, like some dental work that as she was giving her big speech, she felt pop off in her mouth. And so she paused with her tongue to put it back in to cover her tooth back. And the pause was so long, the room became quiet. And then once she got her crown back over her tooth, she finished her line and the casting director said that was the most powerful audition we
去上他的课。他会给你最好的建议。但我想现在我把它放在我的播客上了。所以抱歉，罗伯特。我的表演教练做了类似的事情。她是一位非常了不起的老年女性，她说她正在为一部电影试镜。她来自法国，她有一个旧牙冠，就像一些牙科工作，当她发表大演讲时，她感觉到它在嘴里弹了出来。所以她用舌头停顿了一下，把它放回去，盖住她的牙齿。那个停顿太长了，房间变得安静了。然后一旦她把牙冠放回牙齿上，她完成了她的台词，选角导演说那是我们
have ever seen. She got the heart. And so she was like, so sometimes you know, a pause. That's my first impression. But and it does. It's like, it's the one moment that doesn't make sense. And people are like, why doesn't that make sense? That's such a good way to distill the common thread of those two things. Yeah. Yeah. Well, okay, we actually wanted to talk to you also about what it was like to shoot those two days in the school. You had a huge big group of kids in a classroom. What was it like directing such a big group like that? I guess an advantage of mine is I love talking to kids and groups of kids. Now, they were probably looking back 18 because the way the
见过的最强大的试镜。她得到了那个角色。所以她就像，所以有时你知道，一个停顿。这是我的第一印象。但是，它确实。它就像，这是唯一一个没有意义的时刻，人们就像，为什么那没有意义？这是一个提炼这两件事共同点的如此好的方式。是的。是的。好吧，好吧，我们实际上也想和你谈谈在学校拍摄那两天是什么感觉。你在教室里有一大群孩子。执导这样一大群人是什么感觉？我想我的一个优势是我喜欢和孩子以及成群的孩子交谈。现在，他们可能回顾过去18岁，因为
guilds work, you can work very different hours because the child labor for a kid over 18 or even over 16, the rules are very different. So you'll generally cast people who just turned 18 and look young or just turned 16 and look young for roles that are supposed to be younger. So those kids will probably sell you over a team. That said, they were still like, you know, they kid energy playing kid. I just love talking to kids. You know, when I read my kids book, the book with no pictures, like a classroom, it's like the happiest I am. So I guess to me being like, all right, everybody, here's what happened. You know, this guy, Michael Scott, Steve over here, he did this. You know, they knew it. They got into it again.
工会运作的方式，你可以工作非常不同的时间，因为对于18岁以上甚至16岁以上的孩子，童工规则非常不同。所以你通常会选择那些刚满18岁看起来年轻或刚满16岁看起来年轻的人来扮演应该更年轻的角色。所以那些孩子可能会卖给你超过一个团队。也就是说，他们仍然像，你知道，他们孩子气的能量扮演孩子。我只是喜欢和孩子交谈。你知道，当我读我的儿童书，《没有图画的书》，就像一个教室，这是我最快乐的时候。所以我猜对我来说就像，好吧，大家，发生了什么事。你知道，这个家伙，迈克尔·斯科特，史蒂夫在这里，他做了这个。你知道，他们知道。他们又进入了状态。
You talk to everyone like their actors, including the background actors because it was mostly background actors in the class. Most kids didn't speak. So just getting them, you know, in the mindset of it was really fun for me. They were real, you know, they had good spirit. They're professionals. And then I think it was Lee and Jean because the writers are so involved on the office or were so involved. I think it was it was they who taught the kids like the chant and the dance. And they were amazing. I love Steve's speech so much. I love his delivery of his speech. You know, from the beginning that he's going to have to tell them he's going to have to give this speech.
你像对待演员一样对待每个人，包括背景演员，因为班里大部分是背景演员。大多数孩子不说话。所以只是让他们，你知道，进入那种心态对我来说真的很有趣。他们是真实的，你知道，他们有很好的精神。他们是专业人士。然后我认为是李和吉恩，因为编剧在《办公室》中非常投入，或者非常投入。我认为是他们教孩子们像口号和舞蹈。而且他们很棒。我非常喜欢史蒂夫的演讲。我喜欢他演讲的表达方式。你知道，从一开始他就必须告诉他们，他必须发表这个演讲。
But everything about it is so great. He tries to get them to figure it out so he doesn't have to say it, which is amazing. And then he hands out the batteries, lithium, not laptops or tuition, but some batteries, lithium batteries. Yeah. Yeah. Was that just Steve knowing Michael Scott so well? Yeah. Yeah. That was just Steve doing them so well. I maybe someone pitched maybe the exact phrasing of and what's better than laptops, but laptop battery or what do you need for laptops? I don't know. But it's a collaboration because you see where Steve's going. So you might pitch him a line. But that was, yeah, that was Steve completely. You know, what also was great acting was in the photo where he surrounded by the kids
但关于它的一切都太棒了。他试图让他们自己弄清楚，这样他就不用说了，这太神奇了。然后他分发电池，锂电池，不是笔记本电脑或学费，而是一些电池，锂电池。是的。是的。那是史蒂夫太了解迈克尔·斯科特了吗？是的。是的。那只是史蒂夫做得太好了。我也许有人提议，也许是“什么比笔记本电脑更好”的确切措辞，但笔记本电脑电池或你需要什么笔记本电脑？我不知道。但这是一个合作，因为你看到了史蒂夫要去哪里。所以你可能会给他提一句台词。但那是，是的，那是史蒂夫完全的。你知道，还有什么伟大的表演是在照片里，他被孩子们包围着
phrased on his desk, like even that is good photo acting, his optimistic smile. Yes. Oh my gosh. He directed and he said it was so much easier than acting. And I thought, I thought, wow, that shows how much he's putting into the acting. I mean, this is, like always, he was the total leader of this episode. He had so much. I mean, he just had to thread that needle and he did it so well. We do want to talk to you about the movie you have coming out that you directed. Can you share with us about it? It's cool. It's called Vengeance. And I wanted to do it. I saw a poster for a movie called Vengeance at the Cannes Film Festival
放在他的桌子上，甚至连那都是很好的照片表演，他那乐观的微笑。是的。天哪。他执导了这部剧，他说这比演戏容易多了。我想，哇，这显示了他对演戏投入了多少。我的意思是，这就像往常一样，他是这一集中绝对的领导者。他有很多戏份。我的意思是，他必须在刀尖上行走，而他做得非常好。我们确实想和你聊聊你即将上映的电影，那部你执导的电影。你能和我们分享一下吗？很酷。它叫《复仇》。我想拍它。我在戛纳电影节上看到了《复仇》的海报
and I thought, I want to be in a movie called Vengeance. And I thought, but in a fun way, I was like, if I were in a movie, if you saw me on a movie poster, a movie called Vengeance, you'd know it was different. You know, it wouldn't be like, well, he's a cool action star. You'd be like, that's interesting. What would that, what's that tone? And honestly, that's where it came from at first. And then I had this plot idea that was, I just thought really cool. And yeah, so I took it to, to Blummas because they had just done Get Out, which I thought was another movie that they had been really popular despite having such challenging, interesting ideas. Cause I didn't just want to make a thinky thing. I wanted
我想，我想拍一部叫《复仇》的电影。我想，但以一种有趣的方式，我在想，如果我拍了一部电影，如果你在电影海报上看到我，一部叫《复仇》的电影，你会知道它与众不同。你知道，它不会是那种“哦，他是个很酷的动作明星”。你会觉得，那很有趣。那会是什么，那是什么基调？老实说，最初就是这么来的。然后我有了这个情节构思，我觉得真的很酷。是的，所以我把它带给了布鲁姆豪斯（Blumhouse），因为他们刚拍完《逃出绝命镇》，我觉得那是另一部非常受欢迎的电影，尽管它有如此具有挑战性、有趣的构思。因为我不想只拍一部烧脑的东西。我想要
it to be fun and funny and, you know, scary and all those things. So I mean, it was great to get to direct my first feature that had all of those elements, you know, that has Wait, did you write it and direct it and you're in it? Mm hmm. Wow. Triple threat, BJ. Oh, come on. Three very unthreatening professions, I will say is a caveat. No one's scared of someone who does those three things.
它既有趣又好笑，你知道，还要吓人，所有这些元素。所以，我的意思是，能执导我的第一部剧情长片，并且包含所有这些元素，真是太棒了，你知道，它有……等等，你既是编剧又是导演，而且你还在里面演？嗯哼。哇。三项全能，BJ。哦，得了吧。我得说，这三个职业都非常没有威胁性，作为一个警告。没人会害怕做这三件事的人。
BJ, when does your movie come out? July 29th. Vengeance out. BJ, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies. We love you. I love it. I love it. I love you both. I don't see you enough. I love talking to you. I love remembering it from this lens with the two of you. It's great. You've always been one of my favorite people from the time I met you working on this show. So I love you.
BJ，你的电影什么时候上映？7月29日。《复仇》上映。BJ，非常感谢你来到《办公室女士》。我们爱你。我爱它。我爱它。我也爱你们俩。我见你们见得不够多。我喜欢和你们聊天。我喜欢通过你们俩的视角来回忆这段经历。这太棒了。从我在这部剧里见到你的那一刻起，你就一直是我最喜欢的人之一。所以我爱你。
Well, that is what a wonderful thing to say. And I feel exactly the same way in media bonds. And I noticed, I was going to say, I noticed Angela's silence here. And I would say I feel very similarly about Angela, but if it's not requited, what are you going to do? BJ, I love you so much. I know. I felt that about both of you from the pilot, really. Okay. See you soon. Family for life. Family for life, BJ. Love you so much. Bye.
嗯，那真是太棒了。我也同样有这种感觉，媒体纽带。我注意到，我正想说，我注意到安吉拉在这里沉默了。我会说我对安吉拉也有同样的感觉，但如果这不是双向的，你又能怎么办呢？BJ，我太爱你了。我知道。从试播集开始，我就对你们俩有这种感觉，真的。好的。回头见。永远的家人。永远的家人，BJ。太爱你了。再见。
Well, that was so fun, Angela. I love talking to BJ. I love that we got into that cool discussion about directing. I felt like it's when we had Mike Sherron and we were talking all about the writing process. I know. I could listen to BJ talk all day. Truly, he's so smart. I love him so much. I love his brain. I told him that. I said, BJ, I love your brain. Is that a weird thing to say to someone? No, I love his brain as well. It's so good to be back in the studio. Hi, Cassie. We missed you.
嗯，那太有趣了，安吉拉。我喜欢和BJ聊天。我喜欢我们进行了关于导演的那场很酷的讨论。我觉得这就像我们请来迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）讨论整个写作过程的时候一样。我知道。我可以听BJ聊一整天。真的，他太聪明了。我太爱他了。我喜欢他的大脑。我告诉过他。我说，BJ，我喜欢你的大脑。对别人说这种话很奇怪吗？不，我也喜欢他的大脑。回到演播室真好。嗨，卡西。我们想你了。
Hi. Welcome back. Thank you. Yes. I guess what we haven't shared with everyone was that we actually took a two week break from the podcast. We made sure to double record episodes so that you didn't miss us. But we were off recording the audiobook for the Office BFFs. Oh my gosh. You guys, I mean, I listened to audiobooks. I have a newfound respect for how they come together. We sat in a room together and read all day. It was a teeny tiny little like padded room. Truly. And we read our book. One day at lunch, I had hummus. Oh, yeah.
嗨。欢迎回来。谢谢。是的，我想我们还没和大家分享的是，我们实际上从播客中休息了两周。我们确保双倍录制了剧集，这样你们就不会错过我们。但我们当时在录制《办公室闺蜜》（Office BFFs）的有声书。天哪。你们，我的意思是，我听有声书。我对它们是如何制作出来的有了全新的尊重。我们坐在一个房间里读了一整天。那是一个非常非常小的隔音室。真的。我们读了我们的书。有一天午餐时，我吃了鹰嘴豆泥。哦，是的。
And after lunch, my stomach kept making all these noises because I had a spousy hummus. It was so embarrassing. We had to stop the audiobook. And our amazing director, Dennis, had to go get a pillow and cover my stomach with a pillow. And he said, don't worry, Angel. It happens all the time. Yeah. And then the next day, it happened to me. So the next day we're recording our audiobook. We both have pillows on our stomachs. Oh my gosh. It was so embarrassing. But so much fun. You guys, I can't wait for you to hear the audiobook. We put our heart and soul into it. And so many office castmates
午饭后，我的肚子一直发出各种声音，因为我吃了鹰嘴豆泥。太尴尬了。我们不得不停止录制有声书。我们出色的导演丹尼斯不得不去拿一个枕头，用枕头盖住我的肚子。他说，别担心，安吉拉。这种事经常发生。是的，然后第二天，这事发生在我身上。所以第二天我们录制有声书时。我们俩的肚子上都放着枕头。天哪。太尴尬了。但太有趣了。你们，我迫不及待想让你们听到这本有声书。我们倾注了心血。而且很多办公室的演员同事
make these great appearances in the audiobook. I'm really proud of it. I can't wait for you guys to hear it. Yeah. We really wanted to make it something separate from the book. You know, in the book, you're going to get to see all of our personal photos. So we thought, well, how could we put some special audio surprises in the audiobook? So we can't wait for you to hear it. Yeah. Our friends and castmates really came through. Well, it's available for pre-order now wherever you listen to audiobooks. And I think we should start breaking down the set.
在有声书中都有很棒的客串。我真的很为它感到骄傲。我迫不及待想让你们听到它。是的。我们真的想让它成为独立于书之外的东西。你知道，在书里，你可以看到我们所有的个人照片。所以我们想，嗯，我们怎么能在有声书里加入一些特别的音频惊喜呢？所以我们迫不及待想让你们听到它。是的，我们的朋友和演员同事们真的帮了大忙。嗯，它现在可以在任何你听有声书的地方预订了。我想我们应该开始拆解这一集了。
Let's do it. Let's do it. This episode begins with a hilarious cold open. It's Andy and Michael and Michael's office. And guess what? Andy's baby talk is back. I loved it. I love that Michael makes Andy read his baby talk off a card. Oh, Jenna, I got so tickled in this scene. I literally like was giggling when Michael then reads Andy's baby talk back to Andy. I mean, you have to hear it. You have to hear it. You are also on record as saying widow, ittle, footy, woody's, numb, numb, jammies, make boom, boom, with dick a wuss and wode. I wouldn't.
开始吧。开始吧。这一集以一个搞笑的冷开场开始。是安迪和迈克尔在迈克尔的办公室里。你猜怎么着？安迪的婴儿语又回来了。我喜欢它。我喜欢迈克尔让安迪照着卡片读他的婴儿语。哦，珍娜，我在这一幕里笑得好开心。当迈克尔把安迪的婴儿语读回给安迪时，我真的在咯咯笑。我的意思是，你必须听听。你必须听听。你也有记录说“寡妇，小脚丫，麻木，果酱，制造砰砰声，带着迪克·阿·沃斯和沃德”。我不会的。
Do I sometimes replace ours with W's? Do I sometimes repeat a word to get my point across? Well, if I do, he and he saw we can't be a baby in the office. It makes me look like I hire babies. When he says it makes me look like I hire babies, he says it so seriously. You know, Angela, my cat, Andy, he used to say, ridiculous. When things bothered him, he would say, Oh my God, that is ridiculous. It's so silly, ridiculous mobile. You mean when you did your voice of your cat, Jenna? I channeled what he was actually saying. Angela, Janice has voices for all of her pets. Yep. Sonny has one. Maggie has one.
我有时会用W代替R吗？我有时会重复一个词来表达我的观点吗？嗯，如果我这么做了，他和他说我们不能在办公室里当婴儿。这让我看起来像是我雇佣了婴儿。当他说这让我看起来像是我雇佣了婴儿时，他说得太严肃了。你知道，安吉拉，我的猫，安迪，他过去常说，荒谬。当事情困扰他时，他会说，天哪，那太荒谬了。太傻了，荒谬的移动。你是说当你模仿你的猫的声音时，珍娜？我引导了他实际在说的话。安吉拉，珍娜为她所有的宠物都配了音。是的，桑尼有一个。玛吉有一个。
Yeah. Oh, what's Maggie's? I know. I know Sonny's. Maggie's. This is like this. Hey, guys. Hey, did you want this shoe? Do you want it? You can have it. Hey. Oh, what's that? Oh, look, that orange fell is back again. Yeah, Maggie's just so optimistic about everything. She's joyous. Maggie's joyous. Although every single morning in our house, it is like Groundhog Day. It is like Maggie is meeting Sonny for the first time. Every morning she reacts like, Oh my God, there's a cat in the kitchen. I must follow it. I must get it. What is it? And they do this whole routine. And then about 45 minutes later, everybody's fine again.
是的。哦，玛吉的是什么样的？我知道。我知道桑尼的。玛吉的。是这样的。嘿，伙计们。嘿，你想要这只鞋吗？你想要吗？你可以拿去。嘿。哦，那是什么？哦，看，那个橙色的毛球又回来了。是的，玛吉对一切都太乐观了。她很快乐。玛吉很快乐。虽然每天早上在我们家，就像《土拨鼠之日》。就像玛吉第一次见到桑尼一样。每天早上她的反应都是，天哪，厨房里有一只猫。我必须跟着它。我必须抓住它。那是什么？他们做完这一整套流程。然后大约45分钟后，大家又没事了。
But every morning, every morning, she is seeing the cat for the very first time in her life. Oh my gosh. It's crazy. That's crazy. Well, that's ridiculous. This scene ends with Andy complimenting Michael's Elvis impression. He said other people don't like it, but I like it. And Michael says, this made me laugh so hard. Michael goes, you're welcome, baby. Oh, it's too good. Well, the main plot of this episode is going to get started when Andy bursts into Jim's office. Yeah, Dr. Tuna MD. We have terrible news. We have a serious case of the Mondays. And there's one cure. We need an employee of the month contest. Background catch in this scene. Tell me.
但每天早上，每天早上，她都是这辈子第一次见到这只猫。天哪。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。嗯，那太荒谬了。这一幕以安迪称赞迈克尔的猫王模仿秀结束。他说别人不喜欢，但我喜欢。迈克尔说，这让我笑得太厉害了。迈克尔说，不客气，宝贝。哦，太棒了。嗯，这一集的主线剧情将在安迪冲进吉姆的办公室时开始。是的，金枪鱼博士医学博士。我们有可怕的消息。我们得了严重的“周一综合症”。只有一个治愈方法。我们需要一个“月度最佳员工”竞赛。这一幕里的背景捕捉。告诉我。
One minute, 54 seconds. Hang with me here over Andy's shoulder through Jim's clear glass panel. What do you see at front reception? The golf picture still on the wall. That's right. This is seven weeks. This has been going on. Here's Pam's painting. Right after this is an Andy talking head. I had to bring it up, you guys, because he mentions he spent a summer at Enron. What all is Andy doing in his summer? So add it to the list. We have that he spent a summer at Enron, a summer in Toulouse, a princessing to be a faux magie, and he spent every summer at a dialect camp from age seven to 18 and then went on to be a counselor for 10 years. What is happening with Andy's summers?
1分54秒。跟我一起看，透过吉姆的透明玻璃板，看安迪的肩膀。你在前台看到了什么？墙上还有那张高尔夫照片。没错。这已经是第七周了。这事一直在持续。这是帕姆的画。紧接着是一个安迪的访谈。我必须提出来，伙计们，因为他提到他在安然公司度过了一个夏天。安迪的夏天都在做什么？所以把它加到名单里。我们有他在安然度过了一个夏天，在图卢兹度过了一个夏天，假装成一个伪魔术师，而且他从7岁到18岁每年夏天都在方言营度过，然后又去当了10年的辅导员。安迪的夏天到底发生了什么？
How long are his summers? Very long. They're very crowded with things. I love this next scene so much, Angela. Aaron is helping Michael attempt to clean out his inbox. It hit a little too close to home for me personally. Did it? Mm-hmm. One of my favorite things that Aaron says, she says he has a news alert for Nip Slip. Mm-hmm. And he says, oh my gosh, that must be hackers. So there was another line in the script before Jim comes in to interrupt. Aaron had a line where she said, you also have a news alert for Niple Slip. And I thought that was so funny. I wish it had stayed in. But instead, we needed to get Jim in there. Well, Michael has 836 messages in his inbox,
他的夏天有多长？非常长。它们被各种事情挤满了。我非常喜欢接下来的这一幕，安吉拉。艾琳正在帮助迈克尔尝试清理他的收件箱。这对我个人来说有点太感同身受了。是吗？嗯哼。艾琳说的一件我最喜欢的事情，她说他有一个关于“走光”的新闻提醒。嗯哼。他说，天哪，那一定是黑客。所以在吉姆进来打断之前，剧本里还有另一句台词。艾琳有一句台词说，你还有一个关于“走光”的新闻提醒。我觉得那太搞笑了。我希望它能保留下来。但相反，我们需要让吉姆进来。嗯，迈克尔的收件箱里有836条信息，
and I just want to point out that my email is in worse shape than Michael's. Oh no, lady. I told me last night you cleared a bunch of stuff. I did, but it's just still so large. That's what she said. You need to organize it by unread and then go through and just click on all the ads and stuff that you never get rid of. I'm trying. See what it says now? 15,589. Yeah. My inbox is worse than Michael's. What is yours, Jenna? Like 7? 8. Oh, I was so close. 8 unread. And I think one of those is still one of those. Do you get those from Baby Center where they're still telling you about your kids and milestones? Remember when you first signed up for them, you were pregnant and then they were like a lima bean
我只想指出，我的电子邮件比迈克尔的还要糟糕。哦，不，女士。昨晚告诉我你清理了很多东西。我清理了，但它还是太大了。这就是她说的。你需要按未读邮件整理它，然后浏览并点击所有你永远不会处理的广告之类的东西。我在尝试。看看现在显示多少？15589。是的。我的收件箱比迈克尔的还糟。你的呢，珍娜？大概7个？8个。哦，我太接近了。8个未读。我想其中一个还是那个。你收到那些来自Baby Center的邮件吗？他们还在告诉你关于你孩子和里程碑的事情？记得你刚注册时，你怀孕了，然后他们就像一颗利马豆
and then they were like an orange and then yeah. What I get is today in your memories from Shutterfly and then I click on it and it like brings me to tears all the time because it's my daughter being adorable. Well, maybe you want to keep those, but the other ones you got to click unsubscribe. You got to stop the flow. I got to stop the flow. I'll help you one day. Okay. Well, listen, Jim is going to come in and he's going to pitch this employee of the month idea and Michael's like, sure, go for it. But now we're going to find out what's really going on because Andy is going to tell Dwight that Jim totally went for their idea of employee of the month. And Dwight's like, no, no, that was your idea, your idea.
然后他们就像一个橙子，然后是的。我收到的是Shutterfly的“今日回忆”，然后我点击它，它总是让我热泪盈眶，因为那是我女儿可爱的样子。嗯，也许你想保留那些，但其他的你得点击取消订阅。你得阻止这种流量。我得阻止这种流量。有一天我会帮你的。好的。嗯，听着，吉姆要进来了，他要推销这个“月度最佳员工”的想法，迈克尔说，当然，去吧。但现在我们要找出真正发生了什么，因为安迪要告诉德怀特，吉姆完全采纳了他们关于“月度最佳员工”的想法。德怀特说，不，不，那是你的主意，你的主意。
Dwight's up to something. What he's up to is that in six hours, Jim will be fired by David Wallace. I'm interested to see how that goes down. Well, in the break room, Pam is eating yogurt. When Aaron enters to ask her to look over an itinerary. That's right. We had a fan catch from Kelsey in Kentucky who said, when Phyllis, Pam and Aaron are in the break room looking at the itinerary, it's very obvious again how much purple is in the wardrobe design. Oh, I noticed. And later in the bullpin, you'll noticed Angela Martin also has a purple lilac cardigan. It was a purple day. You and Kelsey are sharing a brain today. We are. Well, this itinerary has one very interesting line item. Pam is
德怀特在搞什么鬼。他搞的是，六小时后，吉姆就会被大卫·华莱士解雇。我很有兴趣看看那会怎么发展。嗯，在休息室里，帕姆正在吃酸奶。当艾琳进来请她查看行程表时。没错。我们收到了来自肯塔基州凯尔西的粉丝捕捉，她说，当菲利斯、帕姆和艾琳在休息室看行程表时，服装设计中紫色有多少再次非常明显。哦，我注意到了。后来在办公区，你会注意到安吉拉·马丁也穿了一件紫丁香色的开衫。那是紫色的一天。你和凯尔西今天共用一个大脑。我们是。嗯，这个行程表有一个非常有趣的条目。帕姆
surprised to learn that the Michael Scott Foundation is still in existence. And Phyllis says, what's Scott's thoughts? And Stanley starts laughing and says, has it really been 10 years? I mean, Stanley isn't just laughing. It is a laugh that comes like from a deep place of like, oh, this guy is screwed. And I am thrilled to watch it happen. Well, Stanley is going to hold up a newspaper. The headline reads, local businessman pledges college tuition to third graders. We kind of talked about this with BJ a little bit. And we got a fan mail flurry about this newspaper article that Stanley is holding up. Because it looks like the real Scranton Times. It really does. This is fakie Phil Shea, but it's done amazingly.
惊讶地发现迈克尔·斯科特基金会仍然存在。菲利斯说，斯科特的那些孩子怎么了？斯坦利开始大笑，说，真的已经10年了吗？我的意思是，斯坦利不仅仅是在笑。那是一种来自内心深处的笑声，就像是，哦，这家伙完蛋了。我很高兴看到它发生。嗯，斯坦利要举起一份报纸。头条写着，“当地商人承诺为三年级学生提供大学学费”。我们和BJ稍微聊过这个。我们收到了一堆关于斯坦利举着的那篇报纸文章的粉丝邮件。因为它看起来像真的《斯克兰顿时报》。它确实很像。这是假的道具，但做得太棒了。
It is actually a real Scranton Times newspaper. Randy Cordray explained how we made this amazing prop. So first they hired a group of kids to take a picture with Michael Scott at school. And Kim Ferry even styled Steve's hair in a retro Caesar style hairdo. You know that one that was made popular by George Clooney in the early years of ER. Oh, yes. Yes. I mean, that's how detailed they were about this photo. They think Michael Scott would be into this hairdo. So then Phil Shea contacted the Scranton Times and asked for a copy of their newspaper from 10 years ago. And when he was looking through it, he said, do you think you would be willing to reproduce the local page? So not the front page, but the
它实际上是一份真正的《斯克兰顿时报》。兰迪·科德雷解释了我们是如何制作这个惊人的道具的。首先，他们雇了一群孩子和迈克尔·斯科特在学校合影。金·费里甚至为史蒂夫设计了一个复古的凯撒式发型。你知道那个在《急诊室的故事》早期由乔治·克鲁尼普及的发型吗？哦，是的。是的。我的意思是，他们对这张照片的细节要求就是这么高。他们认为迈克尔·斯科特会喜欢这个发型。所以菲尔·谢联系了《斯克兰顿时报》，要求提供一份10年前的报纸副本。当他浏览时，他说，你认为你们愿意复制本地版面吗？不是头版，而是
local page with a different feature story at the bottom of the page so that we can use it on our show. Wow. So the writers wrote a fake article and Randy Shamansky, who worked at the Times, put it all together. He put his name as the writer in the byline and printed it for us. Nice, Randy. Thank you. Well, that's why it looks so real. Yeah. Well, there's photos of it online and there's also someone off as tally and I'll put some of those in our stories. Yes. The entire text of the article is on office tally.com. And I thought I would read one of my favorite passages. The whole thing is worth a read. But this one really goes with the episode. Okay. It says, Talib Johnson, a student in Alice Kay's class,
本地版面，在页面底部有一个不同的专题报道，这样我们就可以在我们的节目中使用它。哇。所以编剧们写了一篇假文章，在《时报》工作的兰迪·沙曼斯基把它整合在一起。他把自己的名字作为作者写在署名栏里，并为我们打印了出来。不错，兰迪。谢谢。嗯，这就是为什么它看起来那么真实。是的。嗯，网上有它的照片，还有人在Office Tally上发了，我会把其中一些放在我们的故事里。是的。文章的全文在officetally.com上。我想我会读一段我最喜欢的段落。整篇文章都值得一读。但这一段真的很符合这一集。好的。它说，塔利布·约翰逊，爱丽丝·凯班里的学生，
has dreams of becoming a doctor. Talib's mother has already been trying to save for the daunting $120,000 cost of medical school, and she was not sure if it could ever be a reality. But now that Scott has offered to pick up the tab, Mrs. Johnson said that Talib would undoubtedly be going to an Ivy League university. That's in the article. It's very on theme. I know. Well, Jenna, I have a little section I'm calling according to the internet. Oh, yeah. When you type in Scott's tots, lots of stuff comes up. I'm going to share three with you. The first one is, according to the internet, you might ask yourself how much money would Michael have to pay for all of their tuition? Oh. Assuming all 15 of Scott's
梦想成为一名医生。塔利布的母亲一直在努力为医学院那令人望而生畏的12万美元学费存钱，她不确定这是否能成为现实。但现在斯科特主动提出承担这笔费用，约翰逊夫人说塔利布无疑会进入常春藤盟校。那就在文章里。非常符合主题。我知道。嗯，珍娜，我有一个小版块，我称之为“根据互联网”。哦，是的。当你输入“斯科特的那些孩子”时，会出现很多东西。我要和你分享三个。第一个是，根据互联网，你可能会问自己，迈克尔需要为他们所有的学费支付多少钱？哦。假设所有15个斯科特的
tots attended a four-year private university, Michael would probably have to pay something around $1.9 million. Wow. Yeah. So when he made this promise 10 years ago, he believed he would have so much money that he'd have like an extra $2 million. That's right. Number two. If you go to Oklahoma State University in Stillwater, Oklahoma, you can join a student club called Scott's Tots. What does Scott's Tots do? According to the online newspaper of the school, the O'Colly, staff reporter Jake Sellers wrote, members of the Scott's Tots Club meet weekly to stream and test their knowledge on NBC's The Office. This semester, the club started fresh, mostly meeting and classroom building on Wednesdays. And it goes
孩子都上了四年制私立大学，迈克尔可能需要支付大约190万美元。哇。是的。所以当他在10年前做出这个承诺时，他相信他会有很多钱，以至于他会有额外的200万美元。没错。第二。如果你去俄克拉荷马州斯蒂尔沃特的俄克拉荷马州立大学，你可以加入一个叫“斯科特的那些孩子”的学生俱乐部。斯科特的那些孩子俱乐部做什么？根据学校的在线报纸《O'Colly》，特约记者杰克·塞勒斯写道，“斯科特的那些孩子”俱乐部的成员每周聚会，观看并测试他们对NBC《办公室》的了解。本学期，俱乐部重新开始，主要在周三的教室大楼聚会。它继续
on to say, although this club may be a time for some students to watch a show, for some it is a time to connect. Haley McCauley, senior business manager, is the secretary of Scott's Tots. McCauley joined in the fall of her freshman year and she says they have trivia nights with prizes for the winners and quote, she says, it's a really fun club. Hmm. The article also included a flyer they had made for their club. I'm going to put it in our stories. Oh, I love it. It's got a gym face on it and a dundee. Yeah. And the stapler in the jello, it says it has their campus link. And this is what it says. We watch the office show and have trivia nights once a month. We have snacks exclamation point. Well, you
说，虽然这个俱乐部对一些学生来说可能是看剧的时间，但对一些人来说，这是建立联系的时间。海莉·麦考利，高级商务经理，是“斯科特的那些孩子”的秘书。麦考利在大一秋季加入，她说他们有带奖品的琐事之夜，引用她的话说，“这是一个非常有趣的俱乐部。”嗯。文章还包括了他们为俱乐部制作的传单。我会把它放在我们的故事里。哦，我喜欢它。上面有吉姆的脸和一个邓迪奖杯。是的。还有果冻里的订书机，上面有他们的校园链接。它是这样写的。我们观看《办公室》节目，每月举行一次琐事之夜。我们有零食，感叹号。嗯，你
and I are going. I know. And then it says where you can join to be a member. And according to the internet number three, I found a ton, like too many to list youth soccer teams named Scott's Tots all across the United States. Wow. You can go cheer on Scott's Tots at almost any soccer field on a Saturday in America. So that's some stuff I found on the internet, but we should go back to the break room because Pam has a very different reaction than Stanley to this information. I mean, Pam uses the word terrible like five times. Yeah. She feels like she's not getting through to Michael. She's like, why would you promise something like that? This is a terrible thing, Michael. This is terrible. It's just terrible. And
和我都要去。我知道。然后它写着你可以加入成为会员的地方。根据互联网第三点，我发现了一大堆，多到数不清的青年足球队叫“斯科特的那些孩子”，遍布美国各地。哇。你可以在美国的任何一个周六，在几乎任何一个足球场为“斯科特的那些孩子”加油。所以这就是我在网上发现的一些东西，但我们应该回到休息室，因为帕姆对这个信息的反应与斯坦利非常不同。我的意思是，帕姆用了五次“可怕”这个词。是的。她觉得她无法说服迈克尔。她说，你为什么要承诺那样的事情？这是一件可怕的事情，迈克尔。这太可怕了。这简直太可怕了。而且
she's like, you have to go tell them now. Did you see the article, Angela, where it sort of broke down? There are two reactions to this episode from viewers. You're either a Stanley or a Pam. Like it was saying, you're either a person who laughs through tragedy. You know, you're that person at the funeral who gets the giggles or you have no sense of humor about it. They were sort of saying like, if you're a Pam, you probably can't watch this episode. Right. It's a really interesting article actually. It's on decider.com. And I don't know which one I am. I mean, I have a visceral reaction at like, I feel so bad for these kids. And I also see Stanley finally getting to see Michael get his comeuppance.
她说，你现在必须去告诉他们。安吉拉，你看到那篇文章了吗？它分析了观众对这一集的两种反应。你要么是斯坦利，要么是帕姆。就像它说的，你要么是一个在悲剧中大笑的人。你知道，你是葬礼上那个会咯咯笑的人，要么你对它毫无幽默感。他们是在说，如果你是帕姆，你可能看不了这一集。对。这其实是一篇非常有趣的文章。它在decider.com上。我不知道我是哪一种。我的意思是，我有一种本能的反应，比如，我为这些孩子感到难过。我也看到斯坦利终于看到迈克尔得到了报应。
Yes. I don't know which one I am either. I enjoyed this episode. So I guess I must be a little Stanley. Maybe we're a combo. I don't know who that would be. Are you an Aaron then? Aaron seems horrified. And yet also she still finds a positive spin at the end. Yeah, maybe we're Aaron. The article said about people who are Stanley's. And I thought this was worded really well. They're not heartless. They're almost shocked to the point of hilarity. Right. Something is so insanely absurd to you that someone could do that that you're like, what? That's their coping mechanism. Yeah. Right. Whereas Pam, it's just all just torturous. Yeah. Well, I was really disappointed because I didn't
是的。我也不知道我是哪一种。我很喜欢这一集。所以我猜我一定是个小斯坦利。也许我们是混合体。我不知道那会是什么。那你是个艾琳吗？艾琳看起来很惊恐。然而，她最后还是找到了积极的一面。是的，也许我们是艾琳。文章谈到了那些是斯坦利的人。我觉得这句话写得很好。他们不是铁石心肠。他们几乎震惊到了滑稽的地步。对。某件事对你来说太荒谬了，有人竟然能做出那种事，以至于你会说，什么？那是他们的应对机制。是的。对。而帕姆，这一切简直就是折磨。是的。嗯，我很失望，因为我没有
get to go with Michael as an actor. I wanted to see Pam take Michael to this moment in his life. But Pam refuses to go. Right. Aaron's going to have to do it. But I was very jealous as an actor. That you didn't get to go spend the day with Steve and watch him do these amazing scenes. Yes. Well, Michael now has this famous talking head. We talked about it a little bit with BJ where he says, I just, you know, I fell in love with those kids. And so he made him a promise. He wanted to help them. He wanted to see them graduate from high school and he would pay for their college. Yes. This is sort of the explanation behind this predicament, behind the premise for this episode. We got a fan question from
作为演员和迈克尔一起去。我想看帕姆带迈克尔去他生命中的这一刻。但帕姆拒绝去。对。艾琳不得不去。但我作为一个演员非常嫉妒。你没有去和史蒂夫一起度过这一天，看他演这些精彩的戏份。是的。嗯，迈克尔现在有了这个著名的访谈。我们和BJ稍微聊过，他说，“我只是，你知道，我爱上了那些孩子。”所以他给了他们一个承诺。他想帮助他们。他想看到他们从高中毕业，他会支付他们的大学学费。是的。这就是这个困境背后的解释，这一集前提背后的原因。我们收到了一个粉丝问题，来自
Aaron in Oxford, Ohio, who said this, I recently watched the Big Lebowski and there is a specific scene that caught my eye. In the scene, the dude is visiting Mr. Lebowski's house. During the visit, he's given a tour of the study and notices a picture on the wall of Mr. Lebowski surrounded by a bunch of smiling high school age children. The dude asks, Oh, are those Mr. Lebowski's children? To which the butler replies, they're not literally his children. They're the little Lebowski urban achievers, inner city children of promise, but without the necessary means for a higher education. So Mr. Lebowski has committed to sending all of them to college. My question is, did the writers have it in their head
俄亥俄州牛津市的亚伦，他说，“我最近看了《谋杀绿脚趾》，有一个特定的场景引起了我的注意。在这一幕中，老兄正在拜访勒博斯基先生的家。在访问期间，他参观了书房，注意到墙上有一张勒博斯基先生被一群微笑的高中生包围的照片。老兄问，哦，那是勒博斯基先生的孩子吗？管家回答说，他们不是他亲生的孩子。他们是小勒博斯基城市成就者，有前途的内城孩子，但没有接受高等教育的必要手段。所以勒博斯基先生承诺送他们所有人上大学。我的问题是，编剧们是否在脑子里
that Michael saw this movie and that this might have led him to making a similar promise or is it just a coincidence? I had to find out. So I reached out to Gene and Lee who wrote this episode and they said that the idea for this episode actually came from Paul Lieberstein. Paul confirmed this and when I asked him if the idea was inspired by the Big Lebowski, he said no, that he wasn't even aware of that scene in the movie. Paul said that there was a real story of a businessman who did this with extraordinary success back in the 1990s. He thinks maybe it was Chicago. He couldn't quite remember, but it was a high school where the graduation rate was incredibly low, but within the group of kids
想过迈克尔看过这部电影，这可能导致他做出类似的承诺，还是这只是巧合？”我必须找出答案。所以我联系了写这一集的吉恩和李，他们说这一集的想法实际上来自保罗·利伯斯坦。保罗证实了这一点，当我问他这个想法是否受到《谋杀绿脚趾》的启发时，他说没有，他甚至不知道电影里有那一幕。保罗说，在1990年代，确实有一个商人成功地做到了这一点。他认为可能是芝加哥。他记不太清了，但那是一所高中，毕业率极低，但在那群孩子中
that he made this promise to, all of them went to college. And Paul just remembered the photo in the newspaper and he said that seems like something Michael Scott would do, that Michael, because of his good heart and being so sure that he would be a millionaire by the time these kids graduated, that he would want to help and he would make this promise. He said, quote, it felt like a really honest problem coming from this character. So that was the inspiration was this article that he had seen of someone doing this successfully and thinking Michael Scott wouldn't do it successfully though. He'd want to do it, but he wouldn't be able to follow through. Yeah. So he said the idea was his, but Lee and Gene
他向他们做出承诺，他们所有人都上了大学。保罗只是记住了报纸上的照片，他说这看起来像是迈克尔·斯科特会做的事，迈克尔因为他善良的心，并且非常确定在这些孩子毕业时他会成为百万富翁，所以他会想帮忙，他会做出这个承诺。他说，引用，“这感觉像是这个角色会遇到的一个非常诚实的问题。”所以灵感就是他看到的这篇有人成功做到这一点的文章，并认为迈克尔·斯科特虽然不会成功。他会想做，但他无法坚持到底。是的。所以他说想法是他的，但李和吉恩
made it their own. They came up with the dance, the batteries. He said that was all them. But that was the inspiration behind Scott's Tots. Well, I love that. I always love finding out the inspiration for our episodes. It's usually some little thing that just stuck with someone. Yeah. Meanwhile, in the kitchen, Dwight is continuing to act strange. Yeah. He's showering Jim with compliments and then he provides him with a spreadsheet so that Jim can rank everyone based on performance for his employee of the month project. He says he'll run it over to Toby and the accounting department. So it'll just be like totally impartial. They'll run the data. Exactly. Just data-based. Yeah. Did you notice during
把它变成了他们自己的。他们想出了舞蹈，电池。他说那全是他们的功劳。但这就是“斯科特的那些孩子”背后的灵感。嗯，我喜欢这个。我总是喜欢找出我们剧集的灵感来源。通常是一些困扰某人的小事。是的。与此同时，在厨房里，德怀特继续表现得很奇怪。是的。他向吉姆大献殷勤，然后他提供了一个电子表格，这样吉姆就可以根据表现为他的“月度最佳员工”项目对每个人进行排名。他说他会把它交给托比和会计部门。所以这就像完全公正一样。他们会运行数据。没错。只是基于数据。是的。你在
the scene what Reign took out of the fridge at the beginning? His excuse for going into the kitchen is to get something out of the fridge to run into Jim? No. What was it? Mustard. What's he doing with mustard? I don't know. Did he do anything with it? He does nothing with the mustard, but when they pull back wide, there are more things on the counter that he has gotten out of the fridge. He also got out jelly and I think barbecue sauce. Gross. So he's definitely, I guess, heavy in the condiments. Is jelly a condiment? Is jelly a condiment? I mean, you put it on. Is butter a condiment? What is a condiment? Isn't a condiment like, well, I guess, isn't it like the extras? So maybe you're right. I mean,
这一幕中注意到雷恩从冰箱里拿出了什么吗？他去厨房的借口是去冰箱里拿东西来撞见吉姆？不。是什么？芥末。他拿芥末做什么？我不知道。他用它做了什么吗？他没用芥末做什么，但当镜头拉远时，柜台上还有更多他从冰箱里拿出来的东西。他还拿出了果冻，我想还有烧烤酱。恶心。所以他绝对，我猜，沉迷于调味品。果冻是调味品吗？果冻是调味品吗？我的意思是，你把它涂在上面。黄油是调味品吗？什么是调味品？调味品不是像，嗯，我猜，不是像额外的东西吗？所以也许你是对的。我的意思是，
it is a condiment. Like salt and pepper? No, that's a spice. Oh, I'm sorry. The definition of condiment is a substance such as salt or ketchup that is used to add flavor to food. Thank you. Spices are condiments? Look who was right about something. I found a chart that lists the calories in different condiments. Did you know honey is considered a condiment? Well, that makes sense now. They're listing marinara as a condiment. It enhances flavor. Everything enhances flavor. Well, then there's onion enhances flavor, garlic. Does it have to be? Do you have to squeeze it out of a bottle? Does it have to be? Yeah. Does it have to be in something? What is a condiment? I need more information. We need more information
它是一种调味品。像盐和胡椒？不，那是香料。哦，对不起。调味品的定义是像盐或番茄酱这样用于增加食物风味的物质。谢谢。香料是调味品吗？看看谁在某件事上是对的。我找到了一张列出不同调味品热量的图表。你知道蜂蜜被认为是调味品吗？嗯，现在说得通了。他们把番茄酱列为调味品。它增强风味。一切都增强风味。嗯，那还有洋葱增强风味，大蒜。它必须是吗？你必须把它从瓶子里挤出来吗？它必须是吗？是的。它必须在什么东西里吗？什么是调味品？我需要更多信息。我们需要更多信息
on condiments. Hold on. Is jelly a condiment? Jelly and jam are usually viewed as condiments, but peanut butter is not. Salsa is considered a condiment, but guacamole is not. Here's what I'm thinking. Condiments either have to be something you sprinkle or like kind of more of a liquidy form. Not according to Wikipedia, which says a condiment is a supplemental food such as a sauce or powder. Sprinkle and liquid. That supports my theory. If it's more of a solid substance, it's not a condiment. If you can sprinkle it or pour it, it's a condiment. If you can chop it, it's not a condiment. Sprinkle and pour. All right. Are we ready to move on from the condiments? Maybe. Oh no. My God, you're making a lot of...
关于调味品。等等。果冻是调味品吗？果冻和果酱通常被视为调味品，但花生酱不是。莎莎酱被认为是调味品，但鳄梨酱不是。我在想的是。调味品要么必须是你撒的东西，要么是更像液体形式的东西。维基百科不这么认为，它说调味品是一种补充食品，如酱汁或粉末。撒和液体。这支持了我的理论。如果它是更固体的物质，它就不是调味品。如果你能撒它或倒它，它就是调味品。如果你能切它，它就不是调味品。撒和倒。好吧。我们准备好从调味品中继续前进了吗？也许。哦，不。天哪，你制造了很多……
It sounds like, you know what? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. When you do that, it means you disagree. I sing. I sing as a condiment. So when I'm eating a cupcake, I'm eating cake with a condiment on top. Makes sense to me. Really? Jenna's doing it. I knew it. If you're ever in a conversation with Jenna, she goes, hmm, it means she is slightly judging you and disagrees. Well, Wikipedia says peanut butter is a condiment. Clearly, I don't know. Clearly there's a debate. Dwight has put a bunch of random condiments on the counter. He has. I have nowhere to go from there. That's the end. Move on. He clearly isn't intending on doing anything with them. He's just doing busy work so he can set up gym to fail. Next
听起来，你知道吗？对不起。对不起。当你那样做时，意味着你不同意。我唱歌。我把唱歌当作调味品。所以当我吃纸杯蛋糕时，我在吃上面加了调味品的蛋糕。对我来说说得通。真的吗？珍娜在做。我就知道。如果你和珍娜谈话，她说“嗯”，意味着她稍微在评判你并不同意。嗯，维基百科说花生酱是调味品。显然，我不知道。显然存在争议。德怀特在柜台上放了一堆随机的调味品。他放了。我从那里无处可去。那是结尾。继续。他显然没打算用它们做任何事。他只是在做忙碌的工作，这样他就可以设置吉姆让他失败。接下来
up, Michael and Erin are going to arrive at the high school, and I have a little location breakdown for you. Fan question from Cyrus in Bloomfield, Michigan, were the school scenes filmed at a local L.A. school? Yes, they were. We shot the interiors and exteriors at Van I's Middle School, which is a steam magnet school on Vesper Avenue in Van I's, California. We were there for two days, Monday and Tuesday, October 3rd and 4th. By the way, this is also where they shot the school location for the TV show Fresh Off the Boat. Well, I had a recurring guest star on Fresh Off the Boat. Do you know if you ever went to the school? I think we did one day because I was at a PTA meeting. I was like the mean lady shocker.
迈克尔和艾琳要到达高中了，我有一个小地点分析给你。来自密歇根州布卢姆菲尔德的赛勒斯的粉丝问题，学校场景是在当地的洛杉矶学校拍摄的吗？是的，他们是。我们在范奈斯中学拍摄了室内和室外，这是一所位于加利福尼亚州范奈斯维斯珀大道的蒸汽磁铁学校。我们在那里待了两天，10月3日和4日，星期一和星期二。顺便说一句，这也是他们拍摄电视剧《初来乍到》学校地点的地方。嗯，我在《初来乍到》里有一个常驻客串明星。你知道你是否去过那所学校吗？我想我们有一天去了，因为我在参加家长会。我就像那个刻薄的女士，震惊。
Well, there's a lot of great little details at the school. Phil Shea outdid himself. I loved the plaque that said Michael Gary Scott Reading Room. And Erin's like, you're famous. Yes. Michael has cold feet about seeing everyone, but Makayla greets them and insists they just want to give them a big thank you. I know. Makayla was played by Isheba Renee. She posted on Instagram that she still has her shirt from this episode. Oh, she got to keep her Scott's Tots shirt. That's so cool. She was so good. And she is going to lead Michael into this classroom full of kids all wearing Scott's Tots shirts. I mean, huge applause. They're so excited. He's there. We find out that they have prepared something
嗯，学校里有很多很棒的小细节。菲尔·谢做得太棒了。我喜欢那块写着“迈克尔·加里·斯科特阅览室”的牌子。艾琳说，你出名了。是的。迈克尔在见到大家时有点退缩，但麦凯拉迎接他们并坚持说他们只是想给他们一个大大的感谢。我知道。麦凯拉由伊谢巴·雷内饰演。她在Instagram上发帖说她还留着这一集的衬衫。哦，她留下了她的“斯科特的那些孩子”衬衫。太酷了。她太棒了。她要带领迈克尔进入这个满是穿着“斯科特的那些孩子”衬衫的孩子的教室。我的意思是，巨大的掌声。他们太兴奋了。他在那里。我们发现他们准备了什么
for him, which is a song and dance routine. We had a fan question from Harmjen V in the Netherlands. The dance routine of the Tots is awesome. Where did you find these actors' dancers? And Lisa from New Jersey asked who choreographed the dance routine. Well, Randy Cordray shared with us that the choreographer was Tony Gonzalez. And he had done choreography for Bring It On Again and Bring It On All or Nothing. You know, he's currently doing the choreography for the Masked Singer. And he cast the eight specialty dancers. The dancers were Danielle E. Hawkins, Glenda Morales, David Ezel, Katrina Norman, Chris Moss, Oscar Orozco, Jonathan Rice, and Quentin Burdett. We only had two days of rehearsals with the
给他，那是一段歌舞表演。我们收到了来自荷兰的哈姆简·V的粉丝问题。孩子们的舞蹈表演太棒了。你在哪里找到这些演员舞者的？来自新泽西州的丽莎问是谁编排的舞蹈。嗯，兰迪·科德雷和我们分享说编舞是托尼·冈萨雷斯。他曾为《魅力四射》和《魅力四射：全部或全无》做过编舞。你知道，他目前正在为《蒙面歌王》做编舞。他选了八名专业舞者。舞者是丹妮尔·E·霍金斯、格伦达·莫拉莱斯、大卫·埃泽尔、卡特里娜·诺曼、克里斯·莫斯、奥斯卡·奥罗斯科、乔纳森·赖斯和昆汀·伯德特。我们只有两天的排练时间
dancers. They set up a rehearsal space over on our warehouse stage. They were so good. They were so good. There's no way in a million years that I could learn anything like that in two days. No. It's just a gift. You just have it. You know, I danced growing up. There was a time when I could do that. That time is not now anymore. I tried during the pandemic to take up my tap dancing again. I got a little tap dance floor. I remember this. And I was tapping. And I thought, I'm going to learn a tap routine to footloose. Oh. And like you got to cut loose. Yeah. Okay. And I found like an instructional video on YouTube. And I was like, this is going to be great. It's going to be so fun. I mean, it was like 45
舞者。他们在我们的仓库舞台上搭建了一个排练空间。他们太棒了。他们太棒了。我不可能在一百万年里在两天内学会那样的东西。不。这只是天赋。你就是有它。你知道，我从小跳舞。曾经有一段时间我可以做到。那个时间现在不再了。我在疫情期间尝试重新开始我的踢踏舞。我买了一个小踢踏舞地板。我记得这个。我在踢踏。我想，我要学一段《浑身是劲》的踢踏舞。哦。就像你必须切断束缚。是的。好的。我在YouTube上找到了一个教学视频。我想，这会很棒。这会很有趣。我的意思是，它大约45
seconds long. Weeks. Weeks I spent on this very beginner tap routine. I never posted it. I have like a gazillion videos of myself in my garage. Can I tap floor? Can I please see one? Can I please put it in pod stories? Not to laugh at you. Not to laugh at you. Don't laugh with me because I was not even laughing yet. So someone's laughing. Maybe. Maybe. Okay. Well, I thought the dancers did a fantastic job. They did. We also had a fan question from Laura in Warren, Ohio, who said, who wrote the song? Hey, Mr. Scott. Well, Lee and Jean wrote the lyrics for the song and Eve Nelson wrote the music. Eve is an Emmy winning composer who did a lot of specialty work for us, such as composing the music
秒长。几周。我花了几周时间在这个非常初级的踢踏舞上。我从未发布过它。我的车库里有成千上万段我自己的视频。我可以踢踏舞地板吗？我可以看一段吗？我可以把它放在播客故事里吗？不是为了嘲笑你。不是为了嘲笑你。别和我一起笑，因为我甚至还没笑呢。所以有人在笑。也许。也许。好的。嗯，我觉得舞者们做得非常出色。他们做到了。我们还收到了来自俄亥俄州沃伦市劳拉的粉丝问题，她说，谁写的歌？《嘿，斯科特先生》。嗯，李和吉恩写了歌词，伊芙·尼尔森写了音乐。伊芙是一位艾美奖获奖作曲家，她为我们做了很多专业工作，比如作曲
for subtle sexuality. The Webisode. The one we listened to last week. Yes, that Mindy sings. She also did all the music for threat level midnight. I thought we should hear an audio clip of Hey, Mr. Scott. Hey, Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make a dream come true. Hey, Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make a dream come true. You came into a life that made a promise, that made us honest, made us realize. We don't need a compromise because we can have it all, because you made it possible for us to achieve the improbable. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make a dream come true. So good Eve Nelson. Eve coming through again, and
为《微妙的性行为》。网络剧。我们上周听的那部。是的，明迪唱的那部。她还为《威胁等级午夜》做了所有的音乐。我想我们应该听一段《嘿，斯科特先生》的音频片段。“嘿，斯科特先生，你要做什么？你要做什么？让梦想成真。嘿，斯科特先生，你要做什么？你要做什么？让梦想成真。你进入了一个生活，做出了承诺，让我们诚实，让我们意识到。我们不需要妥协，因为我们可以拥有一切，因为你让我们有可能实现不可能。嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，斯科特先生，你要做什么？你要做什么？让梦想成真。”太棒了，伊芙·尼尔森。伊芙再次表现出色，而且
I can't wait now to see threat level midnight. I know and see all that music. It's funny that you bring up the Webisodes because just last week we were talking about it, but I also mentioned the bobbleheads last week, that Joya Balfour, who worked for NBC.com, was gonna bring all these bobbleheads to the set, right? For me to feature in Adventures with Angela. Lady on set that day, she said, Angela, would you like all of these bobbleheads? Like you can have one of all the cast members since you're doing this for us. And I said, oh my God, I would. And she goes, okay, let me, let me see, but I think I can get you a whole set of full cast member bobbleheads. And I was like, oh, that'll be so fun. Maybe
我现在迫不及待想看《威胁等级午夜》了。我知道，看到所有的音乐。你提到网络剧很有趣，因为就在上周我们还在谈论它，但我上周也提到了摇头娃娃，为NBC.com工作的乔亚·巴尔福要带所有这些摇头娃娃到片场，对吧？让我可以在“安吉拉的冒险”中展示。那天在片场，她说，安吉拉，你想要所有这些摇头娃娃吗？就像你可以拥有所有演员的一个，因为你在为我们做这个。我说，天哪，我会的。她说，好的，让我，让我看看，但我认为我可以给你一套完整的演员摇头娃娃。我说，哦，那会很有趣。也许
I'll like line them like on a shelf in my house. That is so cool. Do you have them? Okay. So here's the thing. Years ago, she was like, Angela, I got the bobbleheads for you. When do you want them? And I was moving. And I was like, oh, I'm moving right now. Can we figure out? And Jenna, I don't know. Life happened. Years went by. Joya reached out to me and said, Angela, I've had these bobbleheads for 15 years. What? Like just recently she reached out. Yeah. She was like, they're inboxes. Can I bring them to you? I said, oh my gosh, Joya. Yes. So we met for coffee and we caught up 15 years of life and marriage and kids. And Jenna, she opened up her trunk and it was full of bobbleheads.
我想把它们像这样摆在我家里的架子上。那太酷了。你有它们吗？好吧。事情是这样的。几年前，她说，安吉拉，我为你准备了摇头娃娃。你什么时候想要？当时我正在搬家。我说，哦，我正好在搬家。我们能想办法吗？珍娜，我不知道。生活总是充满变数。几年过去了。乔亚联系我说，安吉拉，这些摇头娃娃我在手里放了15年了。什么？就像最近她才联系我。是的。她说，它们还在盒子里。我可以带给你吗？我说，天哪，乔亚。太好了。所以我们见面喝了咖啡，聊了聊过去15年的生活、婚姻和孩子。珍娜，她打开后备箱，里面全是摇头娃娃。
I took a picture of her standing by her trunk. I now have all of these bobbleheads. That is so crazy. Cause you know, when we were going through all of our bins of stuff for the book, I found an Oscar bobblehead and a Jim bobblehead and a Pam bobblehead and a Dwight bobblehead. That's all I have. I will tell you the bobblehead I didn't know I need, but I definitely needed was Phyllis. Oh, Phyllis is good. Phyllis is so great. Joya went on to tell me while we were having coffee. She said, you know, it's kind of crazy. I've had all these bobbleheads, but I also have something that I think a lot of people wanted, but I ended up getting. And I was like, do tell. Guess who has the original
我拍了一张她站在后备箱旁的照片。我现在拥有了所有这些摇头娃娃。那太疯狂了。因为你知道，当我们为书整理所有储物箱时，我发现了一个奥斯卡摇头娃娃、一个吉姆摇头娃娃、一个帕姆摇头娃娃和一个德怀特摇头娃娃。我就只有这些。我得告诉你，我不知道我需要，但绝对需要的摇头娃娃是菲利斯。哦，菲利斯很棒。菲利斯太棒了。乔亚在喝咖啡时继续告诉我。她说，你知道，这有点疯狂。我拥有所有这些摇头娃娃，但我还有一件我认为很多人想要，但我最终得到的东西。我说，快告诉我。猜猜谁有原版的
unicorn Barbie? What? Yes. And here's Joya sharing about it. The story of how I acquired the Princess unicorn Barbie doll is really fun. I, of course, was a digital producer for the show working at NBC. And I had read the script for Moroccan Christmas, the episode that it appeared in. And I wanted to use it for our Dunder Mifflin Infinity virtual game. And I also wanted to build a website for Princess unicorn because it seemed like this crazy, funny thing that a little website would just be hilarious for. If you're a big fan of the show, you know that we did a ton of these little one off websites all the time. So princess unicorn doll.com was one of them. And what's really
独角兽芭比娃娃？什么？是的。这是乔亚分享的故事。我获得独角兽公主芭比娃娃的过程真的很有趣。我当时当然是NBC该节目的数字制作人。我读过《摩洛哥圣诞节》的剧本，也就是它出现的那一集。我想把它用于我们的“邓德·米夫林无限”虚拟游戏。我还想为独角兽公主建立一个网站，因为它看起来像是一个疯狂、有趣的东西，一个小网站会非常搞笑。如果你是该节目的忠实粉丝，你就知道我们经常做很多这种一次性的网站。所以princessunicorn.com就是其中之一。真正
interesting is that NBC let the domain expire some years ago and someone bought it up and kept the exact same website there. So you can actually go see the website and thank you to whoever bought that and kept the same website up. I appreciate you. So I wanted to use it for the game. It was a virtual item that you could purchase for your Dunder Mifflin office if you were playing the game. And it was a very rare item. So the props department actually gave the doll to me. They had two versions of the doll that they made and they gave me one to photograph back at my office at NBC. So I did that. And for whatever reason, no one at the show asked me for the doll back and the show ended and everyone went on their
有趣的是，NBC几年前让域名过期了，有人买下了它并保留了完全相同的网站。所以你实际上可以去看看那个网站，感谢买下它并保留网站的人。我很感激你。所以我把它用在了游戏中。如果你在玩游戏，这是一个可以为你的邓德·米夫林办公室购买的虚拟物品。它是一个非常稀有的物品。所以道具部门实际上把娃娃给了我。他们制作了两个版本的娃娃，他们给了我一个，让我回NBC办公室拍照。所以我做了。不管出于什么原因，节目组没有人向我要回娃娃，节目结束了，每个人都各奔
separate ways. And I eventually left NBC and this doll came with me and it's been in my house as this kind of prized memento from the show, you know, for almost 10 years I've found this doll. It's the one memento from the show. I don't think I will ever give up because it's it's pretty amazing. So that is my princess unicorn doll story. I cannot believe she has one of the original. They were only two and she has one of them. Well, now I know how to get original props. You have to be like, you know what, I'd love to build a website, but I'm going to need that to photograph it. And then I'm going to just wait for you to ask for it back. And if you don't, you don't. That is amazing. Amazing.
东西了。我最终离开了NBC，这个娃娃跟着我，它一直在我家里，作为节目中一种珍贵的纪念品，你知道，将近10年了，我找到了这个娃娃。这是我从节目中得到的唯一纪念品。我想我永远不会放弃它，因为它真的很棒。这就是我的独角兽公主娃娃的故事。我不敢相信她有一个原版的。总共只有两个，而她有一个。好吧，现在我知道如何获得原始道具了。你必须像这样，你知道吗，我很想建立一个网站，但我需要那个来拍照。然后我就等着你们要回去。如果你们不问，那就算了。这太神奇了。太神奇了。
It was so good to see Joya and Joya. Thank you so much for the bobbleheads. I'll have to like display them and show you guys. Well, on that note, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll check in on Dwight. We'll see what he's up to. And then, oh boy, Michael has a big announcement to make. He does. Dwight is now going around collecting money. He starts with Kevin 20 bucks to chip in for employee of the month per Jim's request. Oscar contributes as well. He doesn't need Dwight's speech during this whole moment. Guess who's playing Solitaire? I saw it. I saw it once again, actively moving cards on her free cell game. Kate Flannery in the background is Meredith playing a very quick game of Solitaire. Listen,
见到乔亚真是太好了，乔亚。非常感谢你的摇头娃娃。我得把它们展示出来给你们看。好了，说到这里，我们休息一下。回来后，我们要看看德怀特。看看他在忙什么。然后，天哪，迈克尔有一个重大公告要宣布。他确实有。德怀特现在到处收集钱。他从凯文那里开始，要20美元，按照吉姆的要求为月度员工捐款。奥斯卡也捐了。他不需要德怀特在这一刻发表讲话。猜猜谁在玩纸牌游戏？我看到了。我又看到了，她正在自由接龙游戏中积极地移动纸牌。凯特·弗兰纳里在背景中饰演梅雷迪思，正在玩一局非常快的纸牌游戏。听着，
Dwight's plan is five minutes ahead of schedule. Right on schedule. It's working. Back at the school, a teacher is up at the front of the room and she is like profusely thanking Michael for following through on his promise to send these kids to school. And then a student gets up and says, basically, you're my guardian angel. Michael is crying. Oh boy. It's just Michael. The way they wrote the scene to build is so great because with each thing, you're getting just a kick to the stomach. And then it ends with Michael. The woman who's giving this thank you speech was played by Monet McKell. I hope I'm saying your name right. She's amazing. She began her career as a musical theater actress. She has been nominated for
德怀特的计划比预定时间提前了五分钟。完全按计划进行。它奏效了。回到学校，一位老师站在教室前面，她正在极力感谢迈克尔兑现了送这些孩子上学的承诺。然后一个学生站起来说，基本上，你是我的守护天使。迈克尔哭了。天哪。这就是迈克尔。他们编写这一场景的方式太棒了，因为随着每一件事的发生，你都会感到心头一震。然后以迈克尔结束。这位发表感谢演讲的女士由莫内·麦凯尔饰演。希望我没念错你的名字。她太棒了。她以音乐剧演员的身份开始了她的职业生涯。她曾获得
an NAACP Theater Award and she performed in an award winning one woman show. She's also had recurring roles on The Good Place and The Defenders as well as a ton of other film and television roles. Well, she set the bar for this scene because it's so heartfelt, her appreciation as you would be because you're sending these kids to college. Like the level of accountability that the scene starts with is like, oh crap, Michael. Oh, Michael. Well, it's Michael's turn to speak. This is the moment. Yeah. The crowd is cheering. Michael says he'll never forget today. Oh, and then he asked the kids for a show of hands.
NAACP戏剧奖提名，并出演了一部获奖的独角戏。她还在《善地》和《捍卫者联盟》中担任常驻角色，以及许多其他电影和电视角色。好吧，她为这一场景设定了标准，因为它非常感人，她的感激之情正如你所预料的那样，因为你在送这些孩子上大学。这一场景开始时的那种责任感就像是，哦糟糕，迈克尔。哦，迈克尔。好吧，轮到迈克尔发言了。就是这一刻。是的。人群在欢呼。迈克尔说他永远不会忘记今天。哦，然后他让孩子们举手。
He wants to know how many of you have ever made a stupid mistake. He's trying to get them on his side before giving them this terrible news. I kind of thought we needed to hear it. Oh, no, really? Oh, God. Oh, God. All right. In this moment, I'm a Pam. Okay, let's hear it. I came here today because I promised you tuition and tuition is very valuable, but you know what's invaluable is intuition. You know what that is? That is the ability to know when something is about to happen. Does anybody out there have intuition? You know what's going to happen next? Nobody? Okay. You're going to make me say it. All right. I am so
他想知道你们中有多少人犯过愚蠢的错误。他试图在宣布这个可怕的消息之前让他们站在他这一边。我当时觉得我们需要听听。哦，不，真的吗？哦，天哪。哦，天哪。好吧。在这一刻，我就是帕姆。好吧，让我们听听。我今天来这里是因为我承诺给你们学费，学费是非常宝贵的，但你知道什么是无价的吗？是直觉。你知道那是什么吗？那是预知某事即将发生的能力。外面有人有直觉吗？你知道接下来会发生什么吗？没有人？好吧。你们要逼我说出来。好吧。我非常
proud of all of you. Derek and LaFerve and Ben and Ayanna and McKayla and Nikki and Jason and I'm sorry. Okay. Sorry for spacing your name. I'm Zion. I'm McKayla's younger brother. Well, Zion, I am not going to be paying for your tuition, which brings me to my main point and that is that I will not be able to pay for anybody's tuition. I'm so, so sorry. Oh, listen, I'm sorry for all the people out there who skip Scott's tots. I just played the worst part for you, you know, the cringiest part. I watched this episode three times. It's usually how many times I watch an episode as we prep each week for the podcast and I
为你们所有人感到骄傲。德里克、拉费尔、本、阿亚娜、麦凯拉、尼基、杰森，我很抱歉。好吧。抱歉忘了你的名字。我是锡安。我是麦凯拉的弟弟。好吧，锡安，我不会支付你的学费，这引出了我的主要观点，那就是我将无法支付任何人的学费。我非常非常抱歉。哦，听着，我为所有跳过《斯科特的托特》的人感到抱歉。我只是为你播放了最糟糕的部分，你知道，最尴尬的部分。我看了这一集三遍。通常这就是我每周为播客准备时看一集的次数，我
might need a break from it now. He goes on to try to be a hero. We talked about this with BJ. He has Aaron wheel in this humongous suitcase, which you think are going to be filled with laptops. Which is some saving grace, a laptop, not college tuition, but a laptop, but no. It's just the lithium batteries for a laptop. Guys, those are fakie batteries. At 14 minutes, 46 seconds, the graphics for the laptop battery boxes were created by our graphic designer Henry Sain and packaged up by Phil Shea. Fakie batteries. Fakie battery. Well, back at the office, Jim's about to have his own cringe moment. I loved how they edited these scenes
现在可能需要休息一下。他继续试图成为英雄。我们和BJ谈过这个。他让亚伦推着一个巨大的手提箱，你以为里面会装满笔记本电脑。这算是一种救赎，一台笔记本电脑，不是大学学费，而是一台笔记本电脑，但没有。那只是笔记本电脑的锂电池。伙计们，那些是假电池。在14分46秒，笔记本电脑电池盒的图形是由我们的图形设计师亨利·塞恩制作的，由菲尔·谢包装。假电池。假电池。好吧，回到办公室，吉姆即将迎来他自己的尴尬时刻。我喜欢他们剪辑这些场景的方式
because you go from Michael being in hot water to Jim being in hot water. Yes. Jim is going to announce the employee of the month. According to this data, it's employee number nine. Who is employee number nine? It's Jim. Oh boy. People are instantly furious. They don't even take a beat to be like, oh, maybe there was an error. No, they're instantly like you. Yes. Jim won $1,000. Yeah. And got his own parking spot. Oh my gosh. He's like, no, no, no. This is obviously a mistake. Who's second on the list? We need the second person on the list. Uh oh. It's Jim's wife, Pam. Oh boy. How is that even possible? But Pam is going to defend herself as the winner. Yeah,
因为你从迈克尔陷入困境转到了吉姆陷入困境。是的。吉姆要宣布月度员工。根据这些数据，是九号员工。谁是九号员工？是吉姆。天哪。人们立刻愤怒了。他们甚至没有停顿一下说，哦，也许有错误。不，他们立刻说你。是的。吉姆赢了1000美元。是的，还有他自己的停车位。天哪。他说，不，不，不。这显然是个错误。名单上第二个人是谁？我们需要名单上的第二个人。哦哦。是吉姆的妻子，帕姆。天哪。这怎么可能？但帕姆要为自己作为赢家辩护。是的，
she's like, no, wait, come on. I didn't miss a day. I came in early. I stayed late and I doubled my sales last month. Mm hmm. And he goes, oh, really? From what? Two to four? Yup. That is one of your most famous memes. I have texted it to people. I texted my own meme to people, the Yup. I have texted an Angela. I rolled a people. My own meme. I see that Yup everywhere, Jenna. I know. And it's so perfect. It made me laugh. Even though I know it, it still made me laugh. It made me laugh while I was doing it. You'd be surprised how difficult it was to get just one word without me breaking. Yup. Mm hmm. Well, it's going to get even worse. You think it can't get worse for Jim, but now there's going to
她说，不，等等，拜托。我一天都没缺席。我早来晚走，上个月我的销售额翻了一番。嗯哼。他说，哦，真的吗？从多少？从二到四？是的。那是你最著名的表情包之一。我发短信给别人过。我把自己的表情包发给别人，那个“是的”。我发过一个安吉拉。我把人们卷起来。我自己的表情包。我到处都能看到那个“是的”，珍娜。我知道。而且它太完美了。它让我笑了。即使我知道它，它仍然让我笑了。我在做的时候它让我笑了。你会惊讶于只得到一个词而不让我笑场是多么困难。是的。嗯哼。好吧，情况会变得更糟。你以为吉姆的情况不能再糟了，但现在会有
be a cake delivered with his face on it. This was a real cake, you guys. We actually ate this cake. We did. I had a slice of it. It was delicious. It was a real distorted angle of John's face. It was a little bit. It was like when someone takes a photo of you and they go like chin up. I actually had my camera on set that day and I took a picture of the cake. I'll put it in stories. The cake delivery man was played by Charlie Sanders, who is a writer, actor and co-producer of Key and Peel, for which he was nominated for an Emmy for outstanding writing three years in a row. I love Key and Peel. Me too. Oh my God. It cracks me up. We hung out with Key and Peel. We did. We were on a private plane with them.
一个印着他脸的蛋糕送来。这是一个真正的蛋糕，伙计们。我们真的吃了这个蛋糕。我们吃了。我吃了一片。它很好吃。那是约翰脸部一个扭曲的角度。确实有点。就像有人给你拍照，他们说下巴抬起来。那天我实际上在片场带着相机，我拍了蛋糕的照片。我会把它放在故事里。送蛋糕的人由查理·桑德斯饰演，他是《基和皮尔》的编剧、演员和联合制片人，他因此连续三年获得艾美奖杰出写作提名。我喜欢《基和皮尔》。我也是。天哪。它让我大笑。我们和《基和皮尔》一起玩过。我们玩过。我们和他们坐过私人飞机。
The only time I've ever been on a private plane. Well, same. Yes. Caesar Palace flew Jenna and Keegan and Jordan to play in this poker tournament. You took me as a plus one. They flew us to New Orleans. We got on this private plane with these guys and we played Euker, the whole plane ride. I love Euker. We couldn't believe other people knew Euker. It's a card game. We love them. They're so fun. The cake is not the last thing on Dwight's list of diabolical plans. No. He riles everybody up, but it only works if people complain to David Wallace. So Dwight starts calling David Wallace's office pretending to be everyone else. It's so good. I actually, I thought we needed to hear it. He is going to leave messages as
我唯一一次坐私人飞机。好吧，一样。是的。凯撒宫飞往珍娜、基根和乔丹去参加这个扑克锦标赛。你带我作为随行人员。他们飞往新奥尔良。我们和这些人上了私人飞机，整个飞行过程中我们都在玩尤克牌。我喜欢尤克牌。我们不敢相信其他人也知道尤克牌。这是一种纸牌游戏。我们喜欢他们。他们太有趣了。蛋糕不是德怀特邪恶计划清单上的最后一件事。不。他煽动每个人，但这只有在人们向大卫·华莱士投诉时才有效。所以德怀特开始给大卫·华莱士的办公室打电话，假装成其他人。太棒了。我实际上，我想我们需要听听。他要留下信息作为
Kevin, as Stanley and as Toby. I think my favorite part is like his body language. Changes. As he's doing all the voice, he's like spinning his hair with his fingertip when he's being Toby. Yeah. He's like all slumped on the ground. Yeah. But here it is. You have to hear it. This is Kevin Malone. Is David there? No, he's on his weekly staff meeting. Can I take a message? Tell him I'm mad at Jim because he's asking us to give money to Pam. This is Stanley Hudson. Jim Halperg is a menace. It's Toby Flenderson. Listen, things are getting really bad down here. Those are so funny to me. But Jenna, there was one more. There was? Yes. It didn't make it in the final cut, but it's in deleted scenes. It's a little
凯文，作为斯坦利，还有作为托比。我想我最喜欢的部分是他的肢体语言。变化。当他模仿所有声音时，他就像在用指尖转动头发，当他是托比时。是的。他就像瘫倒在地上。是的。但就在这里。你必须听听。这是凯文·马龙。大卫在吗？不，他在开每周员工会议。我可以留言吗？告诉他我生吉姆的气，因为他要求我们给帕姆钱。这是斯坦利·哈德森。吉姆·哈尔珀特是个威胁。这是托比·弗伦德森。听着，这里的情况变得非常糟糕。这些对我来说太搞笑了。但珍娜，还有一个。有吗？是的。它没有进入最终剪辑，但在删除的场景中。它有点
R rated, so maybe that's why it didn't make it. Here is Dwight calling pretending to be Meredith. It's Meredith Palmer. Listen, kid, I'm gonna be drunk as a skunk. And you don't know what to tell me about crotch injuries. But Jim Halpert is a prick. Oh my gosh. I know. So imagine David Wallace getting all of these messages. Yeah, Jim is definitely gonna be hearing from David Wallace later. But back at the school, Michael and Aaron are leaving. They are disgraced. But as they're leaving, one of the students runs out and just kind of confronts Michael. He's like, dude, yeah, this is like really messed up. And Michael just apologizes again. And he says, you know what, I'll pay for your books. It's the least
R级，所以也许这就是它没有进入的原因。这是德怀特打电话假装成梅雷迪思。是梅雷迪思·帕尔默。听着，孩子，我会醉得像只臭鼬。你不知道该怎么跟我说胯部受伤的事。但吉姆·哈尔珀特是个混蛋。天哪。我知道。所以想象一下大卫·华莱士收到所有这些信息。是的，吉姆以后肯定会收到大卫·华莱士的消息。但回到学校，迈克尔和亚伦要离开了。他们名誉扫地。但当他们离开时，其中一个学生跑出来，直接与迈克尔对质。他说，伙计，是的，这真的很糟糕。迈克尔又道歉了。他说，你知道吗，我会支付你的书费。这是最起码的
I can do. Yeah. And he's like, okay, well, books are like $1,000. I mean, that's a lot. And Michael's like, that's like $200 a year. And the kid's like, it's $1,000 a year. So Michael writes a few checks for $1,000. He says, please notify me before you cash these. I have to move some money around. Yes. And he has to hold them for like a couple of year each one year. Well, listen, the actor who played the student is so good. His name is Kwame Boateng. He is part of a trio, an acting trio, his brothers they're referred to as the K brothers. He's amazing. He did a bunch of films and television. But now he is actually the CEO of his own company called the Boateng Group. Wow. Yeah. So he's kind of moving
我可以做的。是的。他说，好吧，书费大约是1000美元。我的意思是，那很多。迈克尔说，那大约是一年200美元。孩子说，是一年1000美元。所以迈克尔写了几张1000美元的支票。他说，请在兑现这些之前通知我。我必须周转一些资金。是的。他必须把它们保留几年，每张一年。好吧，听着，饰演那个学生的演员太棒了。他的名字叫夸梅·博阿滕。他是三人组的一部分，一个表演三人组，他的兄弟们被称为K兄弟。他太棒了。他拍了很多电影和电视。但现在他实际上是他自己公司Boateng Group的首席执行官。哇。是的。所以他现在在商业世界里有点
and shaking in the business world now. And we also had a fan catch in this scene from Matthew in Franklin, Indiana at 16 minutes 48 seconds. You can see snow outside the school. Oh yeah, fakey snow. Well, that fakey snow was provided by our special effects technician, Mike Thompson. According to Randy Cordray, it was actually a warm and sunny day in Van Eyes about 75 degrees. But we threw down some fakey snow. Back in Jim's office, he does get a very frustrated call from David Wallace. I think we need to point out at 18 minutes, seven seconds. The feby snow is back. It is the train painting is in Jim's office. The feby snow is back. That is so weird that it was missing for one episode. I don't know.
风生水起。我们还在这一场景中有一个粉丝发现，来自印第安纳州富兰克林的马修，在16分48秒。你可以看到学校外面的雪。哦，是的，假雪。好吧，那假雪是由我们的特效技术员迈克·汤普森提供的。据兰迪·科德雷说，范奈斯那天实际上是一个温暖晴朗的日子，大约75度。但我们撒了一些假雪。回到吉姆的办公室，他确实接到了大卫·华莱士非常沮丧的电话。我想我们需要指出在18分7秒。假雪又回来了。火车画在吉姆的办公室里。假雪又回来了。它缺席了一集真是太奇怪了。我不知道。
Or maybe it's just the way they angled the camera. Maybe you just couldn't see it and I thought it was missing. Well, it's back and make your heart happy. It really did. You know, lady, if you love trains, you should play this board game called Ticket to Ride. I love Ticket to Ride. I know Ticket to Ride. Oh, we just discovered Ticket to Ride. Our friends sent it to us and now my kids are obsessed. Yeah. You've known about Ticket to Ride all this time. I was going to gift it to you. I'm glad you told me you have it. Oh, yeah. Okay. We love games at my house. You know, we're big family game night folks. Well, this was combining two of your loves trains and a game. We also really love the
或者也许只是他们拍摄相机的角度。也许你只是看不见它，我以为它不见了。好吧，它回来了，让你的心快乐。它确实做到了。你知道，女士，如果你喜欢火车，你应该玩这个叫《车票之旅》的棋盘游戏。我喜欢《车票之旅》。我知道《车票之旅》。哦，我们刚刚发现了《车票之旅》。我们的朋友把它寄给了我们，现在我的孩子们着迷了。是的。你一直都知道《车票之旅》。我本来打算把它送给你的。我很高兴你告诉我你有它。哦，是的。好吧。我们家里喜欢游戏。你知道，我们是大家庭游戏之夜的人。好吧，这结合了你的两个爱好，火车和游戏。我们也真的很喜欢
Oregon Trail, old school board game version, not the computer version we grew up on. Now, according to your deep dive last week, would a covered wagon be considered a limousine? Because the driver is separated from the cargo. I think a completely covered wagon would be, yes. What part of the covered wagon is uncovered? Sometimes they have a front flap that they keep open. But I mean, same in a limousine, the little zzzy thing goes down and up. No, I agree. This is me agreeing with you. I think a completely covered wagon with a driver outside would constitute as a limousine. Wow. Limousine. Tell the early pioneers that they were actually taking limousines to the gold rush. They might be surprised.
《俄勒冈之旅》，老派棋盘游戏版本，不是我们长大的电脑版本。现在，根据你上周的深入研究，篷车会被认为是豪华轿车吗？因为司机与货物是分开的。我认为完全覆盖的篷车会是，是的。篷车的哪一部分是未覆盖的？有时他们有一个前襟，他们保持打开。但我的意思是，在豪华轿车里也是一样，那个小东西上下移动。不，我同意。这是我同意你的观点。我认为一个完全覆盖的篷车，司机在外面，应该构成豪华轿车。哇。豪华轿车。告诉早期的先驱们，他们实际上是坐豪华轿车去淘金热的。他们可能会感到惊讶。
Back to this phone call between Jim and David. Dwight kind of overhears that it's not going well, right? He's all excited. He's so excited. Jim's like, I don't know how it happened. Dwight's like, I know how it happened. Dwight goes back in there doing his little mom detective, drops a folder, grabs his spy pin that's been in there the whole time. As it turns out, this phone call that starts out angry ends amicably. David apologizes. He's like, look, I'm taking out some stuff on you. Okay. Hey, am I going to see you at dinner? And Dwight's like, no. I know. He forgot. Jim and David Wallace are chums. They're pals. The final scene with Michael and Erin, they're driving back. Erin can't stop singing the song. Yeah.
回到吉姆和大卫之间的这个电话。德怀特有点偷听到情况不太好，对吧？他很兴奋。他太兴奋了。吉姆说，我不知道它是怎么发生的。德怀特说，我知道它是怎么发生的。德怀特回到那里做他的小妈妈侦探，掉了一个文件夹，抓住了他一直在那里的间谍笔。事实证明，这个开始时愤怒的电话以友好结束。大卫道歉了。他说，看，我把一些东西发泄在你身上。好吧。嘿，我会在晚餐时见到你吗？德怀特说，不。我知道。他忘了。吉姆和大卫·华莱士是好朋友。他们是伙伴。迈克尔和亚伦的最后一幕，他们开车回去。亚伦不停地唱那首歌。
But then she says, you know, Michael, the principal told me that 90% of Scott's tots are on track to graduate, which is 35% higher than the rest of the school. So, you know, you did do a good thing here. This warms Michael's heart. He hasn't always been that nice to Erin. He's kind of abrupt with her. She's not Pam, which he lets her know routinely. And he says to her, you know what, you're doing great. And he wants to know, what does she hope for? Yeah. What would she like for her future? She says she would like to be an accountant, even though she's terrible at math. I will tell you this is a great nod to the webisode series, The Mentor, where Erin tells the accounting department she
但后来她说，你知道，迈克尔，校长告诉我，90%的斯科特托特学生有望毕业，这比学校其他学生高出35%。所以，你知道，你在这里确实做了一件好事。这温暖了迈克尔的心。他并不总是对亚伦那么好。他对她有点唐突。她不是帕姆，他经常让她知道这一点。他对她说，你知道吗，你做得很好。他想知道，她希望什么？是的。她对未来有什么期望？她说她想成为一名会计，尽管她数学很差。我会告诉你，这是对网络剧系列《导师》的一个很好的致敬，在剧中亚伦告诉会计部门她
wants to be an accountant. We talked about it last week and I totally clocked it when she said that. We also learned something about Kevin's story in this moment, which is he was applying for a job in the warehouse and Michael said, you know what? I have a feeling about you. I think you should be an accountant. Well, this episode ends with a tag. All of a sudden Ryan appears in this episode and he finds Dwight's diabolical plan. Yeah, Dwight left it in the copier. He wants in. He wants to take Jim down. That's how this episode ends. Well, I had a couple little tidbits that I thought I would share. I didn't know where to put these. So I'm putting them here at the end. The first was a piece of mail
想成为一名会计。我们上周谈过它，当她说出那句话时，我完全注意到了。我们还在这一刻了解了凯文故事的一些东西，那就是他正在申请仓库的工作，迈克尔说，你知道吗？我对你有感觉。我认为你应该成为一名会计。好吧，这一集以一个标签结束。突然瑞安出现在这一集中，他发现了德怀特的邪恶计划。是的，德怀特把它留在了复印机里。他想加入。他想打倒吉姆。这就是这一集的结尾。好吧，我有几个小花絮，我想我会分享。我不知道把这些放在哪里。所以我把它们放在最后。第一个是一封邮件
we got from Julia S. in Madison, Wisconsin. This is Cringy. She said, I work at a non-profit company and we had a program that ended up being a skratz-tatz reincarnate. Oh no. She said the goal of the program was to encourage parents of elementary school kids to begin putting away a small amount of money every month that would go toward their kids' college tuition. She said, my company promised that if they did that, the company would give a huge scholarship to each child when they began college. But after a couple of years, the company decided it was too big of a promise to pay scholarships to all the kids and the program had to send out an email to let everyone know that the scholarships weren't going to happen.
我们从威斯康星州麦迪逊市的朱莉娅·S那里收到的。这很尴尬。她说，我在一家非营利公司工作，我们有一个项目最终成为了斯科特托特的翻版。哦，不。她说该项目的目标是鼓励小学生家长每月开始存一小笔钱，用于孩子的大学学费。她说，我的公司承诺，如果他们这样做，公司会在每个孩子上大学时给他们一大笔奖学金。但几年后，公司认为支付所有孩子的奖学金是一个太大的承诺，项目不得不发出一封电子邮件，让大家知道奖学金不会发生了。
Oh my gosh. She said, me and my colleagues now cringe every time someone mentions this failed program and when we talk about it, we call it Scott's Tatz. But I can't leave us on that note. So I wanted to leave you with this real life story called Dale's Kids. I want to hear about Dale's Kids. Dale Schroeder was described in his local paper as a simple man who grew up poor, never went to college, never got married, and worked at the same business as a carpenter for 67 years. They said he had a pair of work jeans, a pair of church jeans, and a Chevy truck. When he passed away in 2005, he did not have any descendants. But after nearly 70 years of carpentry and frugal living, he had saved nearly $3 million.
天哪。她说，我和我的同事现在每次有人提到这个失败的项目时都会感到尴尬，当我们谈论它时，我们称之为斯科特托特。但我不能让我们以这种心情结束。所以我留给你这个真实的故事，叫“戴尔的孩子们”。我想听听关于“戴尔的孩子们”。戴尔·施罗德在当地报纸上被描述为一个简单的人，他出身贫寒，从未上过大学，从未结过婚，在同一家公司做了67年的木匠。他们说他有一条工作牛仔裤，一条去教堂的牛仔裤，还有一辆雪佛兰卡车。当他在2005年去世时，他没有任何后代。但在近70年的木工和节俭生活后，他存了近300万美元。
Most of that money went into a scholarship fund, which helped 33 people go to college free of charge. The kids who benefited from this scholarship all gathered recently to talk about the impact that the scholarship had on their lives. They are now doctors, teachers, a therapist. They said that the money came with only one caveat. Their request was, please pay this forward. You can't pay Dale back, but you can remember him and emulate him. And that is the legacy of Dale Schroeder, and they affectionately call themselves Dale's Kids. Oh, that is so lovely. Oh, Jenna, that is wonderful. Well, I had a quote to end this
大部分钱都进入了一个奖学金基金，帮助33人免费上大学。从这个奖学金中受益的孩子们最近都聚在一起，谈论这个奖学金对他们生活的影响。他们现在是医生、老师、治疗师。他们说这笔钱只有一个条件。他们的要求是，请把这份爱传递下去。你不能偿还戴尔，但你可以记住他并效仿他。这就是戴尔·施罗德的遗产，他们亲切地称自己为“戴尔的孩子们”。哦，那太可爱了。哦，珍娜，那太棒了。好吧，我有一句引语来结束这一
episode on, and now I feel bad saying it because that's such a nice sentiment to end on. Well, I still want to hear your quote, lady. All right. This is from cheatsheet.com. All right. We're taking a pivot here, folks. This is about this episode, and I quote, if you're the kind of person who would like watching a taxidermist or perhaps would enjoy watching someone removing a splinter from the hand of a small child, then this episode is for you. Well, that's perfect.
集，现在我因为说它而感到难过，因为这是一个如此好的情感来结束。好吧，我仍然想听听你的引语，女士。好吧。这是来自cheatsheet.com。好吧。我们在这里转个弯，伙计们。这是关于这一集的，我引用，如果你是那种喜欢看标本剥制师，或者可能喜欢看别人从小孩手上取下刺的人，那么这一集适合你。好吧，那太完美了。
That is Scott's Tots. Of course, we owe a huge thank you to BJ Novak for being on the show today. And thank you to Jean Stupnitzky, Lee Eisenberg, Paul Lieberstein, and Randy Cordray, and also to James Carey, who helped me go through some digital clutter. Yes, and joy about for for meeting me for coffee and bringing a trunk full of bobble heads to me and always sharing with us about what NBC.com was doing. And thank you all for sending in your questions. We love you. We'll see you next week. Love you guys.
这就是《斯科特托特》。当然，我们非常感谢BJ·诺瓦克今天来到节目中。感谢吉恩·斯图普尼茨基、李·艾森伯格、保罗·利伯斯坦和兰迪·科德雷，也感谢詹姆斯·凯里，他帮助我整理了一些数字杂物。是的，还有乔亚，感谢你和我喝咖啡，带给我一后备箱的摇头娃娃，并总是与我们分享NBC.com在做什么。感谢你们所有人寄来你们的问题。我们爱你。我们下周见。爱你们，伙计们。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium dot com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问Stitcher Premium dot com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。